[Zene]
Köszöntök minden kedves nézőt. A mai
vendégem Hátszegi Zsolt lesz. Már bele
is fogtunk így a a sűrűjében, ugyanis a
művészetekről beszélgettünk. Zsolt
animátor, dizajner, zenész,
gördeszkázik, két gyerek édesapja,
ezenkívül közösséget épít. Szóval
rengeteg témánk lesz, amiről fogunk
tudni beszélgetni, és én alig várom,
hogy elkezdjünk beszélgetni erről.
Üdvözöllek Zsolt a műsorunkban. Köszönöm
a lehetőséget. Zsolt egy kicsit
mesélnél- arról, hogy hogy kezdtél el
animációval foglalkozni? Azt hiszem,
hogy problémás gyerek voltam. A figyelem
zavar, ADHD, nem tudom minek kell ezt
nevezni, de hogy nem nem voltam egy jó
tanuló. Viszont akkor a tanárok nem
szerettek annyira. Hát igen, tehát ez
erről így konkrétan tudok ilyen kis
pecséteket, ami mai napig él bennem.
De cserében nagyon sokat rajzoltam,
tehát a rajzolás azt
az így végkísért a az
életemen. M voltam itt az udvarhelyi
kórházban agyhártya gyulladással egész
kis vagyis, hogy gyerekkoromban. És az
így megmaradt a szüleimnek is, hogy hogy
a jobb kezemet nem tudtam használni a
perfúzió miatt, de bal kézzel is
rajzoltam. De amúgy meg jobb kezes
vagyok, tehát ez így nekik megmaradt,
hogy egyfolytában kell rajzoljon. Hány
éves volt? Már nem emlékszem, talán hat.
Úgyhogy úgyhogy rajzolás, azért minden
füzetem tele volt
rajzolva, vagy ha nem tele, de azért
kötelező módon mindegyik füzetemben
kellett legyen valami valami rajzocska.
És az
animációhoz amikor megjelentek az
otthoni számítógépek, akkor lett közöm.
lett nekünk is egy ottoni számítógépünk
is. Az akkori hát lehetőségekhez mérten
sikerült valahogy hozzájussak
egy egy próba, egy demo verziójú
animációs szoftverhez, és ott abba
kísérleteztem.
amúgy, hogy mi vezetett rá, tehát ennél,
hogy hogy kerültem el addig a
szoftverig, vagy
vagy elképzelésem sincs. Tehát
egyszerűen nem tudom megválaszolni azt,
hogy ki mutatta, vagy mutat nem mutatta
nekem senki azt a szoftvert, tehát hogy
hogy találtam meg azt a
szoftvert halvány és mihez kezdílozol a
szoftverrel? A kis hát ilyen 13 h éves
lehettem. Hát az akkori humor érzékemnek
megfelelő vicces kis bolondériákat
készítettem, ilyen 10-15
másodperces kis
jeleneteket, ami igazából csak ennyi,
hogy hogy tudom technikailag megoldani
azt, hogy ez vagy az történjen. És
valahol onnan kezdődött,
aztán művészeti
liciben szobrászatot végeztem.
majd egy
képfeldolgozás tantárgyon a tanár minden
óra elején
mutatott rövid animációkat. Ez teljesen
az én világom. Ezek a azt hiszem fél óra
alatti filmeket rövid animációknak
hívjuk és ilyen sortokat mutatott,
amelyik
max megpecsételték az életemet. Tehát én
ezekat imádtam és
és mai napig fontosnak tartom, hogy
amikor tanítok akkor
akkor a diákjaimnak, akik amúgy meg hát
ilyen tömegfogyasztásra alkalmas kis
sorozatokat néznek, vagy
vagy számomra nem feltétlenül
komoly értékkel bíró tartalmakat néznek
nekik, mutassak olyant,
amelyik nagyon mély, nagyon komoly
témákat boncolgató
animációk.
Utána te is ezt az egyetemet
választottad, tehát hogy később úgy hol
végezted az egyetemedet? Ja,
igen. Utána parcium keresztény
egyetemre, reklámrafika szakra mentem,
mivel hogy magyar egyetem, és hírből
hallottam, hogy ott animációval is lehet
foglalkozni. Úgyhogy egyenes út vezetett
engem
Nagyváradra, és ott amit lehetett,
próbáltam mozgóképpel megoldani minden
feladatot, amit
kaptam, ahol lehetett, ott ott próbáltam
a mozgókép médiumával reagálni a tanárok
provokálására, és hát van, aki díjazta,
van aki nem, de én így elég dedikált
voltam, meg egy az első szemeszter
nagyon furán sikerült, mert mert nagyon
nagyon gyúrtam, hogy nehogy lecsússzak
az ingyenes
helyről. És apait, anyait
beletéve elég gyengén sikerült, vagy
lepontoztak a tanárok. És akkor akkor a
második szemeszterben néztem, hogy na
jó, akkor nem erőltetem, csinálom azt,
ami engem igazán bentről érdekel. Ez a
mozgókép volt, és akkor akkor
amit lehetett, úgy oldottam meg, amit
nem lehetett arra így lezseren, egy
ilyen friss le lezser szemlélettel
reflektáltam, és és valahogy a második
szemeszter meg onnantól tovább mindez
ilyen magától ment, úgyhogy úgyhogy
visszakerültem az ingyenes helyre, vagy
már nem volt kockára téve az ingyenes
hely dolga, úgyhogy valahogy így így
folytattam.
illetve az egyetem után viszonylag hamar
felkeresett egy kiállítást tervező cég,
akik múzeumi kiállításokat terveznek, és
akkor azoknak a mozgókép
mozgóképagát készítettem, készítem azóta
is. Elkezdtem egy mesterét a
budapesti ma ma már Metunak
nevezett intézményben, de akkor már
benne voltam az ipartban, tehát 24-ből
28-at kellett volna egy nap, meg 24
órából 28-at kellett volna egy nap
anémak. Úgyhogy a
aztán az egyetemet ott hagytam, de nem
minden órát, mert voltak tanárok, akiket
megkértem, hogy engedjen be a
kurzusairra, mert rendkívüli tudással
rendelkező szakmabéliiek, és az
ragaszkodtam, hogy hogy minél többet
tudjak meg tőlük. Hm. Gondolom, hogy nem
ellenezték. Nem, nem, nem. Nagyon jó
fej. Ez azért olyan érdekes, hogy
valójában a tanárok alig várják, hogy
egy-egy csillogószemű diákot lássanak,
akiknek ott van a szemében a tűz, hogy
hogy szeretnének tanulni, és és amikor
látnak egy ilyet, miért mondjanak nemet?
Gondolom azért benned volt a félelem,
hogy vajon nemet mondanak-e, mi az, hogy
az egyetemet ott hagyod, de-e mégis
bejárnál egy-egy órára?
Elfogadással voltam benne. Tehát néztem,
hogy nyugodtan megteheti, és miért ne?
De jó fejek voltak. Tehát hogyha ha
nemet mondtak volna, és pontosan tudtam
volna, hogy mit kezdek azzal a a
megmaradt időmel. Elmesélnéd röviden
kérlek az életutadat vissza ide a kicsi
Hargita megyénkbe, hogy hogyan kerültél
vissza Budapestről. Hát
dolgoztam
önkénteskedtem,
meg meg csak úgy jártam fel alá és
próbáltam a megtalálni a helyemet.
Nagyon sokat segített a döntésben a
család dolga, tehát egy idő után
világossá vált számomra, hogy a
nagyvárosi élet az az nem nekem való.
megvannak a az előnyei, de sokkal jobban
szeretem ezeket az előnyöket turista
vagy
látogatókénként megélni, mint mint ott
lakóként.
Aztán meg felkeresett a vám géza
művészeti Népiskola, ami a közismertebb
nevén a népművészeti, úgyhogy
népművészeti animációra kértek fel,
animáció tanításra kértek fel ott.
aminek én nagyon örventem, merthogy
én éreztem, hogy szeretnék oktatással,
vagy vagy nekem való, vagy jól esik, és
szóval éreztem, hogy nagyon jó nekem a
tanítás, jól érzem magam benne és és az
a szerep, ami a tanítással jár, az az
van benne szolgál engem feltőlt. Igen. A
szolgálat. Pontosan köszön a szolgálat
fogalma az így segített, vagy az
dominált. És akkor akkor így elfogadtam,
hogy amúgy is tudom, hogy szeretném
csinálni.
Úgyhogy az izgalmas volt, és hát
úgy magától jött. Igazából kicsit
nehezemre volt mondjuk Magyarországon,
hogy hogy a vicceket el kell
magyarázni. És nagyon jól érzés, amikor
olyan emberek között vagy, akiknek nem
kell elmond, hogy azt a viccet azt
viccnek értsék-e, vagy vagy hogy
értelmezzék. Úgyhogy ez ilyen ez ilyen
jó érzés volt. És a másik dolog, hogy
itt van amit
hozzátenni. Tehát mehettem volna
volt volt olyan projekt,
amelyik egy talán álló megvalósulása is
lehetett volna,
ugyanis Cartoon Networknál
dolgozó alkotókkal volt egy interjú, és
egy londoni stúdióba vettek volna fel
animátornak.
Ott viszont egy nagyon kitalált
helyzetbe kerültem volna bele, illetve
nem akartam cserbenhagyni az
akkori munkahelyemet vagy projektet,
amibe beszálltam.
Úgyhogy az annak nemet
mondtam, de nem is bánom mondom, mert
nem egy olyan művész vagyok, hogy
annyira nem érdekel a pénz, aminek ugye
megvan a
hátulütője. Viszont egy, hogy mondjam, a
funkciója vagy a a projekt nemessége az
úgy inkább motivál. Tehát hogyha látom
az értelmét annak és a a hozzáadott
értékeit, akkor az az engem motivál.
És akkor itthon valami ezt hozzátenni.
Tehát az a kicsi, amit én úgy tudogatok,
vagy amit úgy úgy
értéknek lehet nevezni bennem, azt
lehet, hogy itt az itthoni környezetet,
közösséget tudom szolgálni. És ez a
kiállítás
kiállítások anyagai így tényleg vissza
is jön,
hogy amikor amikor készítek egy olyan
munkát, amelyik amelyik tényleg érthető
egy
egy vidéki
állat tenyésztéssel foglalkozó embernek
és kulturális termék, az az nekem egy jó
érzés. Igen, ez érdekes, hogy
megemlítetted többször is, hogy itthon
van mit hozzátenni, mert valójában a
mélyén
tényleg az van, hogy hol van több
potenciál növekedni és és értéket
teremteni. Például Hollandiában, ahol
már egy csomó minden ki van építve.
Például elgondolkoztam azon, hogy ha
most elköltöznék akárhova nyugatra, és
ott tudok egy IT céget létrehozni
nagyobb eséllyel, vagy pedig itthon,
ahol ahol még nincs annyira kiépítve
minden, hogyha most egy kocsmát akarnék
nyitni, vagy bármibe fognék neki,
bárminek fognék neki, valójában itthon,
ahol ismerem is az embereket, sokkal
nagyobb valószínűséggel tudok valamit
létrehozni, mint mint mint külföldön.
Gyakorlatilag úgy értem, hogy mintogyha
te is erről beszélnél, hogy hogy még még
olyan nyersít minden, még nincs
kiépítve. És ezekről is akarok
mindenképpen beszélni veled, hogy hogyan
építjük ki ezt ezt, mert lényegében a
médiaműhe is egy hasonló kezdeményezés,
hogy valaminek nekifogtunk, ami még
nincs kiépítve. Tehát ez a podcast
kultúra itt a régiónkban ez még nem
olyan elterjedt, mint például nyugaton.
Viszont hol tudjunk feljebb? Egy újabb
podcast hol kell elinduljon? Nyugaton
vagy pedig itt? Arra gondoltam, hogy
beszélünk az animációról, de a legjobb
az, ha nézzük. Tehát az animációnak is
ez is a célja. Mit szólnál ahhoz, hogyha
megnéznénk két rövid animációt, amit te
előzőleg elküldtél nekem, és utána
kicsit beszélgetnénk róla ezekről az
animációkról? Nagyon érdekel, hogy
hogyan
készültek, mi van mögötte a
fogaskerékrendszer.
Kájoni János, a ferences rendi szerzetes
pap rendkívül sok oldalú tudós volt.
Tanár, egyházi szerző, vers és
zeneszerző, fordító, zenegyűjtő,
botanikus, orgonaépítő. Orgonista,
kolostorégítő, iskola és nyomdaalapító,
misszionárius.
Egy szóval
Polihistor. Koni egyik fontosabb
megbízása egy orgona megvásárlása
volt. Hoztuk szép öreg orgonát Brasóból,
melyet jobb részre a pogányság mind
elégetett volt. És azután páter Johannes
Koni
orgonista organi fáber újólag még jobban
és szebben mind
felépített. A tatárjárás után nemcsak a
csiksomlyói orgonát és a kolostórt
újította fel, de további orgonákat és
kolostorokat is ébített. Közben még arra
is maradt ideje, hogy jelentős írott
életművet hagyjon hátra.
Gyűjtéseiben egyházi művek mellett
erdélyi és nyugat-európai énekeket,
táncokat is megörökített.
Csiksomjon
nyomdít, hogy híres énekgyűjteményét
kinyomtassam. A magyar nyelvű
énekeskönyv több kiadást megért. Néhol
még ma is használják.
Mai szemmel nehezen elképzelhető, hogy
hogyan tudott a kor nehézségei ellenére
ilyen sok szakterület mesterévé és
messzeföldön elismertté
válnia. Sem munkámat nem kimillettem,
sem fáradtságomat nem szántam, hanem az
Istentől nékem adott kicsin tálentumot
kiosztottam.
Szóval ez egy ez egy zseniális kicsi
videó. Most már többször megnéztem, és
azt látom, hogy mindig van valami kicsi
részlet, amire még nem figyeltem oda.
Neked milyen érzés amúgy ezt nszerre
látni? Tehát hogy hogyan tekintesz rá,
hogy mindegyes kicsi zegzugát már
ismered ennek az animációnak? Még tudod
élvezni?
Tudom élvezni. Ennek a munkának az az
egyik sajátossága bennem, hogy
befejezettnek minősítem.
Tényleg úgy úgy látod, hogy most ez egy
lekereked lekerekített animáció már nem
nagyon tudná hozzátenni?
Lehetne hozzátenni, de nem szolgálná a
kommunikálást.
Tehát ilyen technikai csavarokat lehetne
még betenni, amitől technikailag jobb
lenne, de önmagában ez így szerintem
teljesen jól megáll a lábán. Úgyhogy,
úgyhogy ez, ez egy ilyen egyetlen munka
talán, amelyiket úgy érzem, hogy befej
sikerült befejezni, és és nem tudnám még
tovább bepecselni és piszkálgatni a
pixelekes részleteket. Annyira
hihetetlen ez az időzítés benne. Úgy úgy
most már tényleg többször nézem meg, és
rendesen érződik egy ilyen rit
ritmikussága ennek a rövid animációnak,
tehát hogy hogy a modern kornak az
emberit leköti. először is, hogy ez egy
oktatói videó, de hogy tényleg nem
veszítettem el egy pillanatra se a
fókuszt. Minden egyes másodpercben, vagy
minden két másodpercben valami
meghökkentő dolog történt, valami ami
felkeltette az érdeklődésem. Nagyon
nagyon minőségi volt a
narráció. Maga az animáció ritmikussága.
Egy kicsit mesélnél róla, hogy ez mennyi
idő alatt készül egy ilyen animáció.
Ez a az animáció onnantól fogva, hogy
megrendelte a Hargita megye kulturális
központja, y olyan három hónapot vett
fel, és hárman dolgoztunk rajta a a képi
világán, rendezésen satöbbi. Nyilván,
hogy van hangbérnők meg satöbbi, de a az
animáció egésze a forgatókönyvtől az
körülbelül három három és fél hónapot
vett fel valami ilyesmi. Tehát a
forgatókönyvet azt már készen kaptátok?
Nem, ez ezért ezért is az egyik kedvenc
projektem, vagy a kedvenc projektem,
mert az történt, hogy én bementem a
kedves feleségemmel a kultáris
központhoz, akik csak mint kreatívokkal
szerettek volna velünk beszélgetni, és
elmondták, hogy milyen projektjeink
vannak.
Akkor volt a káoni év, illetve két év.
Mindegy, ez egy fura
sztori. És amikor kijöttem az épületből,
akkor így megfogalmazódott bennem, hogy
ott a könyvtárunk Csíkszerában ott a
könyvtár, van egy iskola, utca satöbbi,
de hogy
igazából nem tudok Káoniról eleget, és
sokkal több ismeret te kéne legyen
szerintem az embereknek róla, illetve
hogyha valakinek inspiráló tud lenni,
akkor akkor meg legyen az.
Úgyhogy kijöttem az épületből és néztem,
hogy hát
akkor megyek az alkotóbarátaimat, Cson
Bort és Tücskét megkeresem.
Összeállítunk egy egy tervet, egy
költségtervet és megkérdezzük, hogy
látják-e benne a fantáziát, volna-e rá
igény. Így jó néhány hónapot
gondolkodtak rajta. Gondolom, hogy addig
beérett, hogy igazából az az összeg,
amiért mi ezt elkészítettük,
az éppen csak, hogy fedi a
költségeinket. De aztán elfogadták,
aminek nagyon örventünk, mert
mert akkor így így
így már láttuk, hogy ez egy ez egy
sorozat kéne legyen. Tehát nem egy olyan
történelmi személyiség van, akiről
sokkal többet kéne tudjunk. hogy
mennyire jó lenne, ha mondjuk egy
történelemtanár, egy zenetanár, egy
földrajztanár satöbbi bevihetni az
iskolába, és a gyerekeknek úgy
mutathatna be egy történelmi
személyiséget, hogy egy ilyen az ők
nyelvükön szóló fiatalos hangnemben
ismerhetnék meg
meg ilyen a figyelmüket nem kéne
megosszák, vagy nem éreznék a
késztetést, hogy elkezdenek közben
szotyizzni, vagy telefonozni, vagy nem
tudom mit csinálni. Amúgy nagyon nehéz,
amúgy nagyon nehéz elírni, hogy hogy az
embere figyelmét akár két percre is
fenntartsa. Igen. Tehát az animáció azt
hiszem, egy nagyon jó eszköz erre,
főleg, hogyha jól meg van csinálva.
Ennek megfelelően ugye drága is,
merthogy ez egy ez egy olyan médium,
aminek a gyártása azért sok teherrel
jár. Illetve nem olyan látványos. Még
a egy kőműves a napvégén látja, hogy mit
mit csinált. Addig mi a napvégén pár
másodpercnyi kis mozgóképet látunk.
Úgyhogy bizonyos értelemben hálátlan.
Ugye a szakmánkba szokták mondani, hogy
az animációhoz három dolog kell.
Türelem, türelem, a türelem. Gondolom,
hogy más szakmák is vannak, ahol ugye ez
a a sláger, de itt kifejezetten
érvényes. És akkor az volt, hogy kicsit
bevezetsz abba, hogy mit mi kerül három
hónapba, mi az, ami a háttérben történik
ilyenkor?
A forgatókönyv, illetve az ahhoz vagy az
követő képes forgatókönyv, vagy
storyibort, az meghatározza, hogy milyen
lesz a végtermék. Tehát ha spórolunk a
forgatókönyvön, vagy vagy a képes
forgatókönyv kidolgozottságán,
illetve nem vagyunk elég figyelmesek,
vagy nem elég figyelmes a kliens adott
esetben, és elfogad egy storyboardot
valahogyan, úgyhogy nem szánt rá elég
időt, akkor könnyen megtörténhet, hogy
nem lesz jó és majd változtatást kér.
Tehát ez egy esszenciális része, hogy
terv szintjén nagyon jól kell működjön.
Erre nagyon hamar rájött Disney például,
hogy hogy erre olyan erőfeszítést kell
tenni, ami ami akkor még nem volt az ő
idejébe jellemző az ipar az iparra.
Úgyhogy ilyen 10 embert
is odarakott egy-egy produkcióján, hogy
hogy ők dolgozzák ki rendesen és az
érzelmi szár rendben legyen, hogy
implikálva legyen érzelmileg a néző. És
a sztoriboot úgy kell elképzelni, mint
egy egy képregényt. Pontosan. egy egy
képregény igazából, amelyik a képek
egymás utánját
szemléltetik, illetve hogy melyik
vizuális tartalomhoz, vagy mi melyik
képhez milyen auditív szöveg jár, vagy
auditív rész jár. És akkor a kettőnek a
a kapcsolata az úgy ad egy képet arról,
hogy kábé az a rész, az a pár másodperc
az hogy fog működni, vagy jól fog-e
működni, túl van magyarázva, alul van
magyarázva, satöbbi. És ezt nagyon
fontos korán detektálni, mert amikor már
gyártásban vagyunk, ott a változtatás az
rengeteg költséggel jár. Volt egy olyan
tapasztalatunk, hogy a családi
sorozat pilot epizódjának a gyártásakor
egy nem kidolgozott animatikkal kellett
dolgozzunk, és az majd a producernek az
hát nem merem megsaccolni se, de több
1000 eurós
többletköltséget jelentett, hogy hogy
utólag kellett módosítani olyan
dolgokat, amik már a forgatókönyv
szinten vagy animatik szinten rég
rögzítve kellett volna legyenek. Úgyhogy
ezért fontos. Aztán jön a képi
kidolgozás, tehát minden jelenetet,
illetve karaktert, azt igényesen meg
kell tervezni, úgyhogy a mozgóképpel
szakszerűen működjön. És ö most így a
nagy filmekbe, nagy
animációs játékfilmekbe egy karakter
tervezése, vagy a főhős tervezése az
akár egy évig is eltarthat, amíg
átmennek rengeteg iteráción, amíg
megfogalmazzák, hogy ez a zseb kell-e
oda, hogy az a kalap az mit mond a
nézőnek. Tehát nagyon fontos ebben
megoldani, hogy ahogy ránézel a
karakterre, a lehető legtöbb információt
tudjál meg róla, anélkül, hogy bármit
mondott volna. És ez ez melós. Ühüm. És
ez még csak a karaktertervezés,
hasonlóképpen a hátterek vagy a
jelenetek egyéb részeinek a
megtervezése. És akkor ha azok is
megvannak, akkor jön a gyártás, amikor
ezeket az elemeket mozgásra bírjuk és
egymásra tesszük és kompozitáljuk.
Úgyhogy valahogy ezek a folyamatok
vannak az animáció gyártásban, és ezek
ezek veszik fel azt az időt, ami erre
szükséges. Tehát most három hónapig
forgattátok, vagyis három hónapig
animáltátok, három hónap után készen
lett ez körülbelül megkérdezhetem, hogy
mekkora költséget, ha most a cégetek el
kéne ezt vállalja, mennyit kérnél érte,
hogy profitot is termelje, ne önmagát
hozza ki?
Nem vagyok esztimálásból jó, de hogyha
így meg kéne állapítani, hogy körülbelül
kell-Európában egy hasonló produkciót
milyen költséggel készítenek
el, az szerintem percdíja egy olyan
legalább 4000 eurótól kezdődne. Hm. És
innen felfelé, tehát ez most egy két
perces animáció volt. Azt jelenti, hogy
hogy 8000€ lenne a kezdő ára ennek, és
8-100 euróra taksálnám most, hogy itt
kellett Európában mennyiért csinálnák
ezt meg.
számít az is, hogy hány karakter van.
Tehát a az az egyik problémája ennek az
iparágnak,
hogy úgy várnak árajánlatot tőlünk, hogy
nem tudjuk, hogy hány karaktert kell
meimálni. És egy karakter, akinek majd
tegyük fel, van legalább 20 csontja,
vagy 20 aspektusa, amelyik a mozgásáért
felel, és azokat mind menedzselni kell,
mind animálni kell. hogyha egy karakter
van benne,
annak x költsége van, de hogyha kettő
van, tehát valamit kell csinálni egy
mellékszereplő, akkor akkor az
megkétszerezi a munkát. Tehát nagyon
nehéz úgy árat adni, hogy nincsen
sztorib, nem tudjuk, hogy melyik
jelenetben hány karakter van, illetve
látszik-e a karakternek mondjuk a lába,
vagy van-e interakció a világával, mert
ezek amik technikailag megnehezítik a
dolgot, hogy valaki egy poharat fel kell
vegyen, kell járjon, kell sétáljon abban
a térben, és a lába nem kéne
csúszkáljon, ugye? Tehát ezek mind olyan
technikai dolgok, amik így megnövelik a
költséget. Úgyhogy ezért rendkívül nehéz
beárazni egy forgatókönyv előtt egy
animációt, legyen szó reklámanimációról
vagy
bármiről. Úgyhogy ez ez egy ilyen terhes
dolog ebben. Igen. Így az üzletember
elkezdett így gondolkozni bennem, és így
azon gondolkozok,
hogy hogyan éri meg valójában egy cégnek
egy két perces animációt megrendelni. Mi
a gyakorlati hasznám? Tehát ez most
nyilván nekem nagyon tetszett ez a
videó, és és meg megvan az oka, hogy
miért tetszett. Láttam, hogy nagyon jó
az időzítése, nagyon informatív volt.
Miért rendeljenek cégek vagy akár
szervezetek ehhez hasonló videókat,
amikor ennyire
drága? Hogy látod, hogy hogy ez hol
térül meg?
Az az érték, amit az animáció
képvisel, az
szerintem egy a civilizációnak egy ilyen
csúcsa, mert a kultúra az mindig akkor
volt a leg
élénkebb, amikor amikor a civilizáció is
a tetején volt, hogy úgy mondjam.
Úgyhogy az, amikor valakinek nagyon jó a
brendje, az identitása, tehát nagyon
nagyon nagyon jól felépíti a az ő
márkáját, amibe beletartozik ugye logó,
tehát mindenféle arculati dolog, de az,
hogy hogyan kommunikál, akkor az
animációval az
ő civilizáltságát, kulturáltságát is
szemlélteti.
Ugyanakkor az a kép, amit a akinek van
egy animációja már a Google
keresőben
sokszor hamarabb találunk olyan
honlapokra, amikor rákeresünk egy
szolgáltatásra, amelyik honlapon van
mozgóképi tartalom is. Ühüm. Vagy van a
videó oszlopja.
Tehát onnantól fogva, hogy van mozgókép,
és főleg, hogyha ez egy
minőségi animált tartalom,
akkor akkor ez egy olyan komolyságot,
egy olyan bizalmat generál, amelyik
amelyiket nem nagyon tud az állókép így
behozni. A másik dolog, am érdekes a
podcastben is megjelenik, hogy annak
ellenére, hogy a podcast műfaját főleg
hallgatják, nem nézik, ennek ellenére ha
nincs videós tartalom is mellé csatolva,
akkor tizenannyian fogják nézni, vagy
bocsánat, hallgatni a podcastet, mert
mert mert az van, hogy az emberek
legtöbbször a zsebükből hallgatják a
Spotify-on, vagy valahol a a háttérbe,
közben vezetnek, vagy főznek, de néha
egy-egy pillanatra odapillantanak, és az
a pár másodperc, amire ami amit arra
arra szentelnek, hogy néznek minket. Az
elegendő, hogy letapogassák, hogy
mennyire hiteles, hogyan vannak
felöltözve, hogyan néznek egymásra ezek
az emberek. Gyanítom, hogy ezt a a az
animáció idő ideje alatt be is
kapcsolják ilyenkor a videó startart,
megnézik ezt a kionis videót, és és
tényleg fontos, hogy annak ellenére
sokkal
költségesebb videós tartalmat is
csatolni egy podcasthe, mintogyha csak
leülnénk és a hangunkat vennénk fel.
Mégis mégis van egy ilyen igényünk. Ez
ezzel ezzel abszolút tudok azonosulni. A
másik dolog a kajonisnál is az van, hogy
a a médium milyensége, tehát azok a a
kis poénok, képi poénok, tehát nem
feltétlenül az van, hogy elmondunk-e
viccet, hanem az, hogy valakinek mondjuk
spagetti keze van és ön feletten őrvend,
vagy ezek a kreatív kapcsolatok, amelyek
nincsenek szájba rágva, ezek fenntarták
fenntartják a figyelmet, miközben nagyon
hatékonyan kommunikálnak egy egy
koncepciót, vagy egy egy nagyon komplex
dolgot.
Úgyhogy ez a másik dolog, amiért a
amikor az animációt érdemes használni,
mert nem kell használni. Amikor valaki
engem megkeres, akkor egyszer
megpróbálom lebeszélni az animációról,
mert nagyon sok mindent filmesen meg
lehet oldani. Vannak azonban olyan
komplex szolgáltatások vagy termékek,
amiket szerintem teljességgel indokolt
animációval kommunikálni, merthogy egy
állókép nem biztos, hogy elég, illetve
nagyon könnyen túl gurítunk egy egy
szöveges valami reklámocskán. Ha van egy
tartalom, amelyik szórakoztat
minket, úgy informál, hogy közben nem
jelent kognitív terhelést, ezek nincs,
ahogy ne működjön igazából. És ebben a
ebben a világban, amikor most tényleg
három másodperced van arra, hogy megfogd
a nézőnek a figyelmét, ezt nagyon okosan
fel kell építeni, vagy nagyon jól ki
kell találni, hogy mely mi az a három
másodperc, amivel indít a videó, és
onnantól már lehet, hogy megnézi a hét
másodpercet, de az is lehet, hogy akkor
végignézi a 15-öt. És erre szerintem jó
médium a az animáció. Igen, ez egy
érdekes, hogy szokták mondani, hogy egy
kép 1000 szóval felér, és akkor ilyen
szempontból egy mozgókép 1000 képpel is
felér. Tehát, hogy ahogy mondod, egy
animáció önmagában, tehát vannak, amiket
nem
tudunk kamerás megoldásokkal, tehát így,
hogy élő felvétellel megoldani. Nagyon
nehéz lenne ugyanazt egy egy diagramot
vagy egy egy asszociációt, vagy egy egy
egész folyamatot elmagyarázni. Viszont
egy animáció nagyon alkalmas erre. egy
folyamatot, például egy reptéri cseként.
Nagyon sokszor látjuk azet az
animációkat, hogy a gyermekeim ilyen
ismételve nézték meg egymás után 20-szor
ugyan mert mert vicces volt és élvezték
és ez az animáció megragadta a
figyelmüket. Ugyanakkor egyszerre meg is
tanulták, hogy mi történik egy ilyen
folyamat során. Ö amikor először
elmentünk egy repülővel, akkor előtte
megnézettük velük ezeket a videókat, és
amikor már konkrétan ott voltunk a a
futószallagnál, abszolút nem féltek,
élvezték, eszükbe jutott az a a hogy
most éppen mi történik. A vicces az,
hogy az egyik reptériőérőr a lányomat ki
is emelte a sorból, és külön lesznelte a
kezét, és és nem fél tőle. Ny én jobban
féltem, hogy most elkezde sírni a
kislányom, vagy pedig, hogy mi fog
történni, mint ő. És és ezt is egy
animációnak köszönhetem.
Úgyhogy, úgyhogy abszolút ennek
örvendnek, hogy így így felhívtad a
figyelmet
erre. A másik videó, amit szeretnék
megnézni veled, és visszatérhetünk majd
utána az animációra, az egy ilyen
összesítés, különböző stílusokból
összevágva egy ilyen kicsi mini
real. Nézzük meg, és utána beszélgetünk
róla.
[Zene]
เฮ เฮ
[Taps]
[Zene]
Szóval ez egy ez egy ez egy nagyon
izgalmas videó volt. Megint számomra azt
láttam, hogy rengetegféle stílus képi
világ ötvöződik itt, és ez nyilván, hogy
jó pár munkádnak a abból összeválogatott
képekből
volt. Az első kérdésem ezzel
kapcsolatban, hogy hogyan döntöd el,
hogy milyen stílusú legyen egy adott
felkérés?
Ez érdekes. Szóval egyrészt azért ilyen
sok rétű, vagy annyira különbözőek ezek
a
jelenetek,
mert mert mindenféle technikát nagyon
szeretek. Nem volt nekem célom, hogy
hogy egy saját stílusom legyen,
amelyikkel
próbálok így betörni a szakma szakma
piacára, hanem engem a technika érdekelt
nagyon. mindig érdekelt, hogy 3D-ben ezt
hogy lehet megcsinálni, 2D-be hogy lehet
rajzolva, satöbbi. Úgyhogy azért ilyen
összetett, és
azért szeretem az én módszeremet, vagy
ezt a
sokalusságomat, a technikai értelmű
sokoldalúságomat, mert könnyebben tudok
hajlani egy olyan alternatíva felé, ami
még jobban szolgálja azt a tartalmat,
amit el kell mondani.
szemléltetésképpen mondanám, hogy
hogy mondjuk van olyan tartalom,
amelyiknél teljességgel indokolt, hogy
3D-s legyen, merthogy olyan jelleggel
kell reprezentálni azt a a témát,
terméket vagy
akármit. De 3D-vel meg nem lehet annyira
érzéki, vagy sokkal nehezebb egy
érzéki oldalt belevinni, és akkor ez más
technikával meg könnyebb. Tehát először
az mi az oka? Ki arra g pont arra
gondolnék, hogy a 3D-ben több információ
van benne, de a két dimenzió az az
leegyszerűsíti a a képi világot. Hogy
lehet abba több érzelmet belevinni?
A elsősorban technikailag egy kicsit
egyszerűbb, tehát költséghatékonyabbá
teszi, de meg tud történni a 2D-be, vagy
könnyebben meg tud történni a 2D-be az,
hogy egy valamilyen formából egy valami
teljesen más forma lesz, vagy egy
formából egy szimbólum, vagy egy
szimbólumból egy szimbólum, vagy egy
emberből egy szimbólum, vagy tehát hogy
át tudnak alakulni a dolgok egymásból.
Ezt 3D-ban rendkívül körülményes és
rendkívül költséges megcsinálni.
Úgy úgyhogy először azt mérem fel, hogy
tényleg mi melyik technika és hogyan
tudja szolgálni azt a tartalmat, amit
amit át kell adni. Ühüm. Meg ilyen
szempontból érdekes, hogy például a
South Park ez egy nagyon jó példa arra,
hogy az egyik legsikeresebb animáció
animációs film az, ami ami gyakorlatilag
olyan, mintogyha papírmasék mozognának,
vagy azt hiszem, hogy így is készült az
első pár két évad, hog hogy ilyen
papír karakterek mozognak, és valójában
teljesen bele tudunk feledkezni abba a
világba, és mert nem ez a lényeg, a
történet, ami mögötte van, az mozgatja
az egész érzelmi szálat, és és már már
elfelejtjük, hogy hogy Azok azok
egyszerű kicsikét dimenziós formák,
ilyen méltani formák. Nagyon jól
kitalált. Az az a baj, hogy zseniális a
South Park szakmailag, tehát az ahogyan
kommunikálnak, meg ahogyan amilyen
időzítéssel implikálják a nézőt
érzelmileg vagy valamilyen
szinten. Szóval szó zseniális az, ahogy
ők megoldják és hát nyilván, hogy ott
nem a kép viszi a prímet.
Ö és az teljesen jól van. Tehát az
kristálytiszta. Nem akarnak annál többek
lenni, mint ami a tartalom. Kép se akar
annál több lenni. Kár is lenne most
minek dolgozzák így Disneysre, amikor
amikor nevetség tárgyába akarnak inkább
tenni dolgokat. Na, nagyon tetszik. És a
miközben kitalálod tegyük fel a
stílusát ráérzel arra, hogy most a 2D
talál ehhez inkább jobban, vagy a 3D a
vonalvastagsága a gondolom, hogy nézel
más munkákat is. Nem tudom Pinterestet
használsz erre, hogy így ilyen
inspiráló.
Igen, néha azt is használok. Tegyük fel
már úgy nagyjából kialakult a kép. Akkor
maga az alkotási folyamat az az hogyan
történik? Milyen
mindsettel alkotsz? hogy hogy mi
történik ilyenkor?
Nehéz ilyen szinten reflektálnom
magamról, mert elég hamar bekerülök egy
ilyen flow statebbe. Tehát nem nem
egyfajta ilyen nagyon tiszta magamat
kívülről látós
tudatosság jut érvényre, főleg a
tervezői fázisban, amikor még még még
nem tudjuk, hogy mi merre megy. és
nagyon
sok problémát kell megoldani, vagy
nagyon sok képi problémára kell
megoldást találni. És ez nagyon nagyon
izgalmas számomra. És olyankor így így
így jön a flow, jönnek az ötletek,
főleg, hogyha még egy olyan
alkotótárssal dolgozok, akkor akkor
egymásra reflektálunk. és egy
hát talán a legkedvencebb része az,
amikor amikor egymás egymásnak tudjuk
mondani, ez zseniális, ez ez zseniális
gondolat volt, vagy ak vagy vagy
oda-vissza mennek ezek a gondolatok, és
nagyon jó
kreatívokkal úgy így dolgozni, mert
nekem van egy vízióm, látom, hogy ez így
működne, vagy ez a egy még igazából
dizájn problémákról beszélünk, hogy egy
koncepciót hogyan tudunk, vagy egy egy
fogalmi dolgot hogyan tudunk képpé
alakítani, mert sokszor nagyon-nagy
nagyon
nehéz, hogy hogyan ábrázolod és és
amikor valaki kreatívval így így együtt
dolgozunk és egymásnak így pattognak a a
labdák, ez a brainstorming, ez rendkívül
jó érzés. Ilyenkor nincsen bennem ilyen
tudatosság, hogy ez a mindsetem, vagy
ilyen Ühüm. Máskor szokott lenni. Tehát
ott amikor amikor tudom,
hogy keretet kell magamnak szabjak, vagy
módszert kell találjak arra, hogy
hatékonyabb legyek. Ühüm. vagy vagy
megoldást kell találjak arra, hogy elég
időm legyen, hogy belekerüljek a a
flowba, hogy tudjak dolgozni és
meg megosztott figyelem nélkül tudjak
dolgozni, azok már mások. Tehát ott már
lehet, hogy kell ilyen módszer,
valamiféle mindset, hogy hogyan kerülök
abba
abba vele ezt így jobban meg kell
tervezni, de alapvetően amikor a
kreatív mármint, hogy a néző számára is
értelmezhető kreatív dolgokról van szó,
akkor akkor az egy ilyen flow. Ez nagyon
érdekes ez a flow. Tegnap beszélgettem
egy egy színművésznővel, aki elmesélte.
Az egyik kérdésem az volt,
hogy ha fáj a hasa, vagy éppen nincs
kedve rossz összevitatkozót tegyük fel a
férjével, és nincs kedve a színpadra
lépni, de viszont ott ott a fellépés,
meg kell oldani, akkor akkor mit tesz?
És azt mondta, hogy ez ezt ő nagyon
sokszor tapasztalta, és más színészek is
ugyanezt tapasztalták, hogy abban a
pillanatban, amihe itt elindul a darab,
minden megszűnik, megszűnik a fájdalom,
megszűnik és belekerül abba a
karakterbe, és teljesen át tudja élni.
nem nem emlékszik már azokra a dolgokra,
amik amik azelőtt zavarták. És miután
lejár a műsor, akkor hirtelen minden
visszatöltődik. Tehát a maga a műsor az
egy ilyen időtlen
egy egy olyan kreatív állapot, amikor
minden
éles,
fókuszált, fájdalommentes, de mégis
játékos. Tehát a játék egy egy része
ennek a flownak.
bármi
lehetséges és valós, tehát nem egy
állomszerű valami, hanem egy valós
éberállapot. Te te így tapasztalod-e
amúgy a a ezt a
flót? Nem, azért nem, mert az előadó
művészet alapvetően nagyon más. Tehát
akkor, hogy mondjam, biokémiai szinten
más az ember összetétele, amikor
színpadra kerül, és úgy kell
teljesítsen. Amikor
viszont barátokkal vagy egyedül egy
ilyen alkotói folyamatot kell megoldani,
akkor nincsen
gyomorideg, tehát nem már más folyamatok
mennek végig.
Úgyhogy talán ilyen szinten nem tudnám
összehasonlítani ezt a két, vagy nem
tudnék párhuzamot vonni a két dolog
között. Milyennek írnád le a te flow
állapotodat?
Maximálisan
fókuszált. Megosztatlan a figyelem még
akkor is, hogyha provokáció van. Tehát
az az érdekes, hogy más helyzetekben
mondjuk megszólal a telefon, vagy vagy
tudom, hogy fel kell vernem, de ha így
az alkotói flow, ami ami ami ritka
gyümölcs, tehát nem az van, hogy
egyfolytában ez van, mert az csak a
produkciónak egy parányi része az első
egy-két
hét, az az ilyen nagyon nagyon
fókuszált, nagyon tiszta, és ilyen
kicsit önfelett, kicsit olyan, mint a a
zenélés önmagunk számára. Tehát ilyen
azt tudom hasonlítani, igen, a amikor
amikor a hangszer mögé ülök, és csak úgy
magamnak terápiás jelleggel zenélek.
Mondjuk eddig két dolog talál, tehát a
az önfeletség, a játék, a az éberség ezt
talál. És a mi a helyzet az
időérzékkel? Tudod, hogy hány nem
létezik időérzék? Akkor már három dolog
talán. És akkor a kérdésem az az, hogy
sok kreatív stúdió ezzel küzd, hogy
például a Pixárnál emlékszem, amikor
olvastam a
a könyvüket, hogy a legnehezebb
számunkra az elején az volt, hogy a a
Toy Storyak a sikere után hogyan tudják
még egyszer megismételni ugyanazt a
sikert. Tehát a a Disney versenyzett a a
Pixarral, és eleinte nem akart szó szó
se szót szóba se jött az, hogy most ő
befektessen a Pixarba. Úgyhogy önmaga
erejéből próbálta a Toy Story kiadni és
hihetetlen nagy siker lett. Akkor
sikerül utána hónapokig ilyen rollerrel
járkáltak a az irodába, és egyszerűen
nem tudtak nekiifogni egy újabb műnek,
mert mert egyszerűen hogyan überbereljék
azt a azt a hihetetlen nagy sikert, amit
a amit a Toy Story aratott.
És egy egy szó szerinti kreatív kihívás
volt, hogy hogyan lehet ezt újra és újra
és újra megismételni, és nekik sikerült.
Viszont leírja konkrétan azt, hogy hogy
milyen szabályszerűségek vannak ahhoz
abban, hogy hogy valaki kreatív tudjon
maradni. Ühüm. Te te ezt hogyan oldod
meg? Van ennek van-e pár dolog, amit már
megfogalmaztál magadnak, hogy hogyan
tudsz te folyamatosan kreatív lenni?
Nem fogalmaztam meg. ilyen szinten az az
én
kreatív folyamataimra nem
nem reflektáltam, nem volt a miért nem
volt provokációra, hogy erre
reflektáljak. Nagyon más lehet, mert az
amit egy ilyen nagy stúdió csinál, és
azt mondják, hogy saját termékük van,
tehát az amit kifejeznek, az egy saját
dolog. Tehát nem az van, hogy egy
kliensnek kell megfelelni, jó
producernek meg nem tudom, meg kell
felelni egy-két dolognak, de attól még
egy alapvetően egy saját dologról van
szó. Amit mi csinálunk
általában, az az ilyen problémamegoldó,
tehát van valakinek a kommunikációs
problémája és azt kell megoldani.
É olyankor bennem nincs ilyen, hogy hogy
jobbat kell csinálni valakinél. Teljesen
elfelehetem azt, hogy szintek vannak,
hogy valaminél jobb. Olyankor bennem az
van, hogy az adott problémát, tehát azt
a valamit, amit ki kell fejezni, hogyan
lehet a legjobban. Tehát legjobb
tudásomhoz képest próbálok egy olyan
képi
leképzést arra a koncepcióra, amelyik
szerintem vagy legalkalmasabb és és
szolgálja a tartalmat.
Úgyhogy nálunk annyira nincs ilyen, hogy
magunkat próbáljuk überberelni, mert nem
nem überberelheted az előző
kliensednek a nem tudom magyarázó
videóját
a vagy hogy mondjam, így így nehéz így
összehasonlítani, mert annyira mások.
Kíváncsi vagyok egy dologra, például
amit megfogalmazott a Pixar magának,
hogy a maguk a rendszerek, amiket
bevezettek a a eleinte, mint így így a
egyre inkább multifele hajló cég
akadályozta meg a kreativitást. Például
volt egy ilyen
brainstorming alkalom, amikor leültek,
és rájöttek arra, hogy egyik oldalról
azt várják el, hogy mindenki jöjjön egy
véleménnyel, másik oldalról viszont egy
hierarchikus volt maga az asztalnak az
elrendezése. Tehát egy egyrészt egy
téglalapú asztalhoz ültek le. Tehát ugye
eleve voltak olyan személyek, akik
távolabb voltak, és voltak akik és ki
volt rakva a konkrét név tábla, hogy
hova kell leülni, és bizonyos személyek
könnyebben hozzá tudtak szólni, és
bizonyos személyek kevésbé. És amikor
erre rájött, tudatosította magába, hogy
valójában a
kreativitás az egy szinergikus csoda, és
abban vannak, akik
ugyanúgy hozzá tudnak tenni, függetlenül
a pozíciójától, hogy egy kreatív új
ötlettel jöjjenek, mint mint az, aki
tegyük fel vezérigazgató. Úgyhogy
kidobták azt az asztalt, és behoztak egy
köralakú asztalt, ami és és már az volt
a szabály, hogy bárki bárhova leülhet.
már önmagában az elrendezkedése a
székeknek azt üzente, hogy te is
beleszólhatsz, függetlenül attól, hogy
mi a pozíciód, mert odaülsz le, ahol
éppen helyed van. És ez elősegítette
önmagában azt, hogy hogy kreatívak
tudjanak lenni. Ez volt például az
egyik, amit ez ez mennyire érvényes így
a ti munkátokra?
Olyan pici az ipar, Romániában akkora
stúdió nincs, hogy probléma legyen az
asztalmérete.
Bár ez lenne a probléma. Bár ez lenne a
probléma.
Hát nem nem voltam nem kerültem még
olyan olyan kontextusba, hogy hogy ez
itt szempont legyen. Gyanom a Cartoon
Networknél azért odakerülhettél
volna. Hát lehet, hogy hogy több ilyen
szalagmunkát kellett volna végezni. Nem
nem már nem emlékszem pontosan, hogy mi
volt, vagy azt hiszem, hogy játékoknak
kellett volna fejlesszünk.
Az az meg megint egy más világ, amikor
játékoknak készítesz
animációt. De ez igen,
ez nekem egyetlen dolog, ami erről
eszembe jut, az inkább az, hogy hogyan
lehet megnyitani a megnyitni a társaink
mondókáját. És tanárként is tapasztalom
azt, hogy lehet, hogy generációs dolog,
lehet, hogy nem.
hajlamosak csendbe üldögélni és
valamiért félnek kifejezni. Félnek
attól, hogy hogy butaságot mondanak,
vagy nem jó az ötletük. Ez Budapest is
jellemző volt, vagy csak itt? Persze, én
teljesen hülyét csináltam magam magamból
Budapesten. Tehát én voltam az az arc,
aki aki feltette azt a kérdést, amire
hátamná hallottam, hogy elkuncogja a
másik magát, hogy hogy most komolyan ezt
a kérdést te feltetted. És az volt az a
kérdés, ami amiután egy fél órás olyan
szakmai beszélgetés indult el,
amelyiknél senkinek esz ágába se volt,
hogy kimenjen cigizni, vagy ilyesmi. Ez
hányszor történik meg, hogy félsz
feltenni egy kérdést? Közben a terem
80%-a ugyanazzal a kérdéssel küzd magába
és féli fél feltenni.
És van egy pár persze, amelyik kacak, de
de ahogy látod, nem indult volna el a
szakmai beszélgetés, ha nem lett volna
releváns kérdés. Igen, ez ez talán nem
tudom, nevezem szupererőmnek, de nem
félek hülyét csinálni magamból, és
ugyanez érvényes érvényes a a hangszeres
mi voltomra is, merthogy nem vagyok
zenész, de tudok lefogni hangokat
egyikmásik hangszeren, és van amelyikkel
vagyok annyira bátor, hogy akár
színpadra is álljak. tisztában vagyok
vele, hogy nem érdemelek meg, hogy ott
legyek, nem érdemelek meg, hogy azokkal
a zenészekkel legyek ott. De hogy
mondják, a játék és
a az a pici, amit el tudok mondani, az
lehet, hogy releváns tud lenni. Ühüm. E
ez nagyon szép, hogy így megfogalmaztad,
mert valójában én én ezt látom, hogy
archetipikus nyelvezettel élve az
archetipikus bolond mindig megelőzi a
megváltót. Vagyis azt jelenti, hogy ha
valaminek nekifogunk, mindig bolondnak
gondolnak elinte, mert mert mert nem
vagyunk ügyesek benne. Most amikor
elkezdtem a podcastemet, az az igazság,
hogy én is egy kicsit bolonddá váltam,
mert az emberek csodálkoztak rajta, hogy
hogy merek kitárulkozni, hogy merek a az
érzelmeimről beszélgetni. Én legutóbb a
feleségemmel ültem le beszélgetni, és
és bizonyos
szempontból kell rizikóztassam azt, hogy
bolondnak gondolnak ahhoz, hogy valami
újat tudjak behozni, akár saját saját
magam számára és mások számára is. És
ugyanígy ezt fogalmaztad te is meg, hogy
a zenével, ha attól félsz, hogy rosszul
fogod csinálni, akkor nem fogod
elkezdeni. Az az igazság, hogy csak
rosszul lehet valamit elkezdeni. Van ez
a másik mondás, hogy ha valamit
csinálsz, akkor csináld jól, de de az
igazság, ha valami új dologba kezdesz,
tuti, hogy rosszul fogod csinálni. Nem
nem szabad félni attól, hogy valamit
rosszul kezdesz el. Érdekes ez a téma. A
Kolozsváron elindítottam egy zenei
műhelyt régebbecske 2014-ben talán a
minden második héten, bizonyos napon
este összeültünk és
és előkészítettem a hangszereket.
szerencsére a a tér adott volt meg a az
eszközök, és akkor elindult egy ilyen
műhely, és az akadémiások, azok, akik a
legképzettebb zenészek voltak, és a
legaktívabb zenészek voltak, ők szóltak
hozzá a legritkábban, vagy ők álltak be
ebbe a zenei műhelybe zenélni a
legritkábban. Miért lenézték?
Elképzelhető az is, hogy úgy érezték,
hogy nem méltóak hozzá. A másik dolog
inkább az az, hogy a képzettségük miatt
nem hogy úgy nem hogy nem méltóak hozzá,
hanem hogy esetleg azok, akik akik
odamentek a azok tegyük fel, lenézték
azokat a személyeket. Nem, nem tudok
ilyenről. Én alapvetően egy nagyon
naivív ember vagyok. Én nem hiszem, hogy
ilyen jó, akkor elfeszegetjük ezt. Igen.
Én én én én szerintem mindenkinek
csillámpóni lelke van. Ö szóval itt az
történt, hogy a a konzis zdenészek
ritkábban, vagy kifejezetten ritkán
jelentek meg, vagy álltak fel a
színpadra, vagy a térbe, mert nem tudom,
hogy ezt mennyire lehet a színpadnak
hívni, mert egyszerűen ha ő hibázik
képzett zenészként, azt ő
nehezebben fogja fel, és az improvizált
zenében a a hibázás az az alapsz. Sőt,
én merném megkockáztatni, hogy egy új
fajta pozitív esztétikai minőséget is
képviselhet.
Ühüm. E nagyon tetszik ez az irány,
ahova elindultunk. Először is ugyanazzal
a színésznővel, vagy színművésznővel,
akivel leültem beszélgetni tegnap,
említette, hogy náluk a tanár, aki az
improvizációt tanította, azzal
bátorította őket, hogy lehet, hogy össze
fog jönni. Több min valószínű nem fog
összejönni. próbálkozol
valahol valahol valami talán összejön és
annak majd örvendünk, megünnepeljük majd
ezt a ez egy teljesen más hozzáállás,
mint arra gondolni, hogy ez össze kell
jöjjön, és ez stúdió minőségű kell
legyen elsőre.
Hát ez jellemző rám amúgy, hogy
hogy el elfogadom, hogy hogy halandó
vagyok, és a hiba az egy olyan dolog,
amiből tanulni kell. Megpróbálom nem
ismételgetni a hibákat. Van úgy, hogy
sikerül, van úgy, hogy nem sikerül, de
nem, én nem szeretnék azzal a félelemmel
élni, hogy hogy hibázok, vagy vagy ez
nekem nem ezt amúgy kiművelted magadban,
vagy egy adottság, hogy hogy nem nem
zavar, hogyha ha nem vagy tökéletes.
Szerintem szerintem azzal jár, hogy hogy
alapból egy nem voltam egy jó tanuló,
egy kicsit kicsit hunc gyerek voltam.
Hozzászoktál ahhoz, hogy megszínak? És
hát, hogy nem csinálok jól dolgokat, ez
ez valahogy így természetes, vagy hát
nézem, hát nem nem vagyok tökéletes, meg
így így csinálok
hibákat, de az én magam módján,
amilyen eszközöm van, próbálok
valamilyen szinten értéket
teremteni. Hibázok. Oké. Most az az a
legnehezebb, hogy
amikor van be van-e az emberben egy
tiszta törekvés
valamire, szeretne szeretne valamit
jobbá
tenni, nem tökéletes a kivitelezés, mert
az energia, a motiváció megvan, az
ismeretekből sose lehet elég. Úgyhogy
valahol mindig hibázik az ember, vagy
nem elég figyelmes, ami ami ugye nálam
még talán gyakrabban is meg tud
történni.
És akkor jön jön egy jön egy olyan
kritika, amelyik szerintem egy kicsit le
tudja tőni az embert, hogy de ember, te
mit tettél? Tehát kapok egy olyan
kritikát valakitől, akinek töredéke
annyi erőfeszítése nincs abban, hogy
valamit jobbá, vagyis, hogy igen, azt a
valamit, amit próbálok építeni, és és
nagyon szívesen nagyon örvendek, ha
valaki társal valami jó törekvésbe.
Hogyha valaki nem akar hozzátenni, csak
csak így mutogatja a a hogy így, hogy
mondjam, így nagyon negatív pályaszéről
kiabál. Igen, igen, igen. És nem akar
hozzátenni. Az az azt meg kell tanuljam
magamba kezelni. Féló, hogy bolond lesz.
És nem is csoda. Nem is csoda, mert
tényleg félelmetes dolog a
megszégyenülés. Ez az egyik legrosszabb
rémálmunk, hogy hogy nekem már ne. Neked
már ne. Igen, nehéz elfogadni, de egy
kicsit térjünk rá erreő a
közösségépítési szándékodra, ugyanis elő
már innen is érződik, hogy hogy
valamiért számodra fontos az, hogy
együtt csinálj másokkal dolgokat. Úgy
ahogy mondtad, hogy ezt a zenei műhelyt
létrehoztad, de
valójában egyrészt mint tanár is
tevékenykedsz, ami megint egy
közösségépítés a a következő
generációnak a az oktatása. Viszont
elindítottad ezt a
a
grafikusok közösségét is. Erről
szeretném egy kicsit meszigner
közösséget. Erről szeretném, hogyha egy
kicsit mesélnél, valamint utána ezt a
Transylvani Design Weeket, amit pont
most a feleségemmel a múlt hétvégén
néztünk
meg. Mi miért hozol mi a célod azzal,
hogy közösséget hozzol
létre? A az improvizációs műhelynél egy
kísérlet volt. Nem tudtam, hogy van-e rá
igény. Az önfelett dolog, az is játék.
játszunk a
hangszeren. A az egy ilyen kísérlet
volt, hogy mi lesz, ha megcsinálják ezt,
mi van, hogyha szabadon csinálunk, és mi
van, hogyha vadidegenekkel beszélgetünk.
A deszignner közösség az egy az egy
nehezebb, mert a a az egy olyan szakma,
amiben lehet, hogy a szakmabilliek már
hát kétszer, háromszor, négyszer tízszer
kiégtek, tehát nem egy olyan önfelett,
nem egy játszós
platform.
Ellenben a Design week szervezése alatt
viszonylag
hamar evidenciává vált, hogy nagyon sok
alkotó, nagyon sok tervező,
grafikus ilyen izolálva él.
nagyon
ö kevés elképzelése van arról, hogy ki
lenne a példakép, vagy milyen alkotókat
kéne kövessünk, nem ismerjük egymást, és
akkor mindenki egy kis buborékba ott
tengeti. Az is kiderült, hogy nagyon sok
probléma van, amit meg kéne oldani.
Tehát nagyon sok
olyan probléma van, például, hogy a az ő
szellemi tulajdonukat, a szerzői
jogaikat sírtik, például azzal, hogy
létrehoznak egy jól kitalált arculatot.
egy cégnek vagy egy
intézménynek, az fel van építve, és
onnantól fogva lehet, hogy átkerül
valaki másnak a kezébe, aki
meg nem teljesen értve a mögötte levő
folyamatot, mondhatni felelőtlenséggel
átszabja azt és újragondolja úgy, hogy
közben az, akinek a szellemi
tulajdonáról van szó, az magyarázkodnia
kell másoknak, mert hogy erre van példa.
És akkor ez is egy olyan dolog, ami
megoldást kíván szerintem. És ezért
gondolkozunk most ezen. Tehát nem lehet
ezt még közösségnek hívni. Ez egy ilyen
kérdőjelecske. Van-e akivel a van-e
akinek csinálni?
Mert hogy ne nehéz téma ehhez, meg
nehéz aktivitásra bírni az embereket,
mert
alapvetően hogy mondjam, nekem mindig
fura, ha valaki passzív, mert én
rendkívül aktív vagyok, de hogy ez ez
még nem született meg, nem vagyunk egy
egy valódi közösség. Úgyom egy olyasmi
is lehet mögötte, hogy van egy ilyen
szakmai féltés vagy féltékenység, hogy
az ötletemet ellopja valaki. Ezt mértük
fel amúgy pont pont egy kérdőívbe és van
aki ilyen középen van, hogy hát azért
van amit tartania a társaitól, de de nem
az van, hogy most félték, mer hát
mindenkinek megvan a a projektje. Még
várom az ered még várjuk az
eredményeket, hogy így tényleg a lehető
legtöbb
csízigjner így kitöltse, és akkor
könnyebben le tudunk vonni konklúziókat,
de nyilván, hogy konkur konkurenciaként
is gondolnak egymásra az emberek. És
például ezt hogyan tudjuk átidan tudjuk
áthidalni, hogyan meg lehet-e oldani?
fel meg tudunk-e fogalmazni egy
olyan eszmét, amelyikben
tényleg korrekt társakként és
alkotótársakként gondolunk egymásra,
mert én az építészeket látom egy igen jó
példának, mert az építészeknek nagyon
komoly szervezeteik vannak, találkoznak,
ismerik egymást és
valami hasonló két szememmel láttam,
hogy ők bennük nincs meg ez a ez a fész
mondjuk az
építészeknél talán kevésbé problémás a
kenyér kérdése, vagy a betáljuk amit ami
amit hát a funkció, tehát hogy
egyszerűen az a az a az a szerep, amit
betöltenek, az egy az egy sokkal
fontosabb szerep, merthogy lakni valahol
kell. Tehát ott egy kicsit más, viszont
példaértékű. Én nagyon szeretnék egy
olyan közösségnek a része, szakmai
közösségnek a része lenni, mint amilyen
közösség a az építész közösség például.
Abszolút. Tehát, hogy hogy amikor
meghallottam ezt a nagyon örventem, hogy
hogy rájöttél ennek a bölcsességére, ami
amire évekkel ezelőtt kellett én is
rájöjek. Valójában bennem is volt egy
ilyen féltés és egy programozó.
hogy
hogy szeretnék-e közösséghez tartozni,
vagy én a kicsi cégemet magányosan
szeretném építgetni. És az egyik dolog,
amire rá kellett jöjjek, arra az az,
hogy a szinergia tényleg csak akkor tud
működni az emberek között, hogyha allén
bedobunk mindent, és mondhatná valaki
azt, hogy hát de valaki ellophatja a
gondolataimat. És az egyik bölcsesség,
amit meg kellett értsek, az az, hogy
maga a terv, a gondolat, az egy
kicsi-kicsi része a munkának, és a
kivitelezés az a nagy része, csak úgy
nem lopják el a gondolatodat. Meg a
másik az, hogy tényleg annyira
zseniálisak a gondolataid, tényleg meg
vagy róla győződve, hogy ott a magányos
kicsi zúgodban
te olyan gondolatokkal jössz, amik
tényleg
korszakalkotóak. Nem pont arról van szó,
hogy egy kreatív tábtalaja lehet az,
amikor beszélgetsz másokkal, és
elkezdtek egymással játszani úgymond.
Tehát a játék az egy nagyon jól
visszatérő motívum. Oda ide-odobáljátok
az a gondolatokat, és lehet mire
mire a végére értek a beszélgetésnek
mind a ketten sokkal gazdagabban
távoztok. Erről egy refle egy
reflektálásom lenne, hogy a a Designwe
megrendezése
magával hozott egy panelbeszélgetést,
vagy ilyen blokkokat, ahol az AI is
nyilván terítékre került, mert nekünk
dizájnereknek is ez egy nagyon komoly
téma.
és Miset Mátyásnak hívták az egyik
előadót, aki szuper jól megfogalmazott
valamit, hogy valaki feltette az egyik
jelenlévő a kérdést, hogy de hogy akkor
féljünk-e egy új innovatív ötletünket
beírni a chat GP? Kérdezzük-e meg a chat
GP-t itt? Mondja az által tanítjuk. És
akkor a Misetics pedig azt mondta, hogy
hát ő úgy gondolja, hogy ahányan vagyunk
a földön, de az amit ő leírna, az elég
kis eséllyel teljesen új, tehát
korszakal hokkotó, ahogy te mondtad,
teljesen ezt ezt kábé nagyon szépen
kibontotta, hogy az ötlet
az majdnem, hogy semmi. A kivitelezet,
hogyan hogyan viszed az ötletet a a
kivitelezésig el, az a valódi érték. Ez
így van. És ez ez megjelenik nagyon sok
szinten is. Elon Musk Elon Musk mondta
például, hogy egy prototípust kihozni
egy autóról az a legkönnyebb egy új
koncepcióval jönni és akár az első
prototípust legyártani. A legnehezebb, a
99%-a, vagy annál több a feladatnak az
az, hogy hogyan válik ebből egy
tömeggyártásra alkalmas cikké.
nagyon-nagyon nehéz mérnöki kérdéseket
kell megoldani. És tényleg így van, hogy
a tervezés az mindig 1% és a a
kivitelezés az a 99%. Ezért tudok
megmosolyogni egy-egy olyan politikust,
amelyik azt mondja, hogy a papírok már
alá vannak írva, már elkezdtük a
dolgokat, a folyamatok már úton vannak,
és azon gondolkozunk, hogy tényleg,
tényleg ezek az érvek. A folyamatot
végigvinni, az a nagy dolog, papírt
aláírni és elkezdeni, az a legkisebb
dolog. Úgyhogy, úgyhogy tényleg ez ezt
ezt jó, ha meg megérti bármelyik
közösség, hogy megéri találkozni, és a
covid is ilyen szempontból egy nagyon jó
kis tanítólecke volt számomra, hogy
megéri fizikailag találkozni, mert
kiéhettük magunkat, távol elkezdtünk
homeoficeokból dolgozni, távolról is
kiluguzódtak a kapcsolatok, ki
kilazultak ezek a kapcsolatok, és és a
minden egyes találkozás szinte ilyen
katartikus élmény most már nekem, amikor
össze tudunk ülni a munkatársaimmal,
úgyhogy mindenki ott van, és elkezdünk
beszélgetni valami komplex témáról, és a
meglepetés mindig minden egyes
alkalommal ott van, hogy az elején a
megoldhatatlan problémának tűnő valami a
végére már szinte nem tűnik
megoldhatlan. Sőt azon gondolkozunk,
hogy erre miért nem gondoltunk hamarabb.
Úgyhogy ez a
fajta ez a fajta személyes találkozás,
ez ezek hihetetlenül izgalmas
dolgok. A kicsit mesélj erről a
Transylvani Design Weekről.
A Transylvanian Design Week
egy nem szokványos dizájnh
hét. A két éve rendeztük meg az elsőt, a
aminek igazából
a az indítványozója a az akkor még
létező vagy Romániában is létező OTP
volt. Úgyhogy akkor egy egyfajta ló volt
adva a projekt alá. Így versenyt
hirdettünk meg, és akkor tervező
grafikusok, formatervezők, ruhatervezők
jelentkeztek, és akkor így létrehoztunk
egy egy
kiállítást, amelyik nagyon-nagyon jól
sikerült. Tehát olyan olyan visszhangja
volt, amiután úgy gondoltam, hogy azért
azért ott kész a slágt egyből ellőttük,
és nem biztos, hogy ezt így még egyszer
meg lehet ismételni. és a kiállítás
főkurátora, Ol Gyárfárs, aki amúgy ha
jól tudom, kétszer is megtervezte a
román olimpiai csapat uniformusát.
egy tusnádi
származású alkotó
és és Gafinak a
a az érdeme, hogy hogy a slágert
überberelte és egy olyan
kiállítást hozott létre, amelyik
szerintem
kisvárost messze überbereli, és
a nagyvárosi látogatók, doktorok, akik
akik jelen voltak a megnyitón, ők úgy
gondolták, hogy ez a kiállítás egy
nagyvárosi kontextusba is bátran
megállná a helyét. Úgyhogy egy egy
nagyon izgalmas kiállítás, egy nagy
felkiáltójel egy csomó
mindenre. Az ami ami problémás egy ilyen
kiállításba, az az, hogy minket,
embereket
vagy mondjam, nem fókuszál annyira az
oktatás arra, hogy megtanuljunk művészet
nézni.
alkalmazott művészetről, iparművészetről
van szó,
de mégis ez a kiállítás egy újabb
alkotás, ez egy művészeti alkotás,
amelyik ami közben rávilágít a az
alkalmazott
médiumoknak a szépségeire és
fontosságára.
Tehát egy egy ilyen furcsa fúzió ez,
ahol ahol a múzeum tárgyaiból is be van
emelve egy csomó minden, és akkor erre
hogyan tudunk reflektálni, és erre nem
tanít meg senki minket. Tehát mondtál
egy ilyet, hogy a művészet a megtanít
minket látni, ez részben igaz, de hogyha
alapvetően nincs meg az emberben a
nyitottság, hogy művészet nézzen, akkor
úgy fog kijönni erről a kiállításról,
hogy mindenféle hülyeségeket rággattak
arra a báburra. És kár volt az időmet
ezzel itt el el De ez tényleg így van.
Tehát a művészek tanítanak meg minket
látni. Tehát hogy azelőtt szerintem az
tehát nem az van, hogy az ős ember
kijött a barlangjából és könny szemmel
nézte a természetet, hogy milyen
gyönyörű a a naplemente, hanem próbálta
túlélni a a a természet
viszonytagságait, a járványokat, a fagy
fagyat fagyot, a a az éhinségeket, és
valójában el kellett jusson oda az
emberiség, hogy tájképeket festettek egy
idő után a művészek. megtanították azt,
hogy ez szép és lehet szebbé
le tud nekünk valami olyasmit adni,
amire alutte nem gondoltunk. És az
összes művészeti hullám egy újabb és
újabb szeletében mutatta be a például az
impresszionizmus, vagy az az
expresszionizmus, vagy ezeket én is
tanulom, sosem néztem úgy azelőtt egy
tárgyra, hogy hogy esetleg a szín az egy
érzelmet is kifejezhet.
Igen, ezek érdekes dolgok, mert hogy a
művészetet meg lehet közelíteni egy
fogalmi oldalról is, tehát azt is
értelmezhetjük valakinek a tályképében,
a festészetében, hogy ő meg akarja
nekünk mutatni a szépet. De azt is
feltételezhetjük, hogy az alkotónak
nincs, nem tud mást csinálni, csak
alkosson. Tehát ő nem ki akar fejezni
valamit nekünk, hanem ő érzi, hogy ki
kell fejezzen. Tehát ez a ez a kényszer,
hogy hogy elmondja egy
alkotói ilyen turet szindróma, hogy hogy
ki kell fejezzen. És a nagy zenei
zeneszerzők is így voltak, hogy nem
tudnak nem zenét írni. és hogy mögötte
mi a gondolat, vagy vagy belement-e
annak a koncepciójába, ő arra
gondolta-e, hogy akkor ezt egy ilyen
koncepció mentén viszik el, az az ő
munkamódszere. De elképzelhető, hogy ezt
a verset József Attila nem úgy írta,
hogy közben nagyon fogalmi, konceptuális
síkokon próbálta összerakni, hanem
egyszerűen egy egy fogalmakkal nehezen
alátámasztható kis vonalon írt val
hozott létre egy új művet is. Ez a
képzőmészete jellemző, hogy hogy sokszor
jövünk, hogy miért, és mindig meg kell
válaszolni azt, hogy miért, és mindig
fogalmakba kapaszkodunk, és ebbe vagyunk
belenevelve, hogy hogy mi amikor látunk
valamit, vagy csinálunk valamit, akkor
meg kell érveljük és ott kell legyen.
Közben meg van egy olyan oldala az
embernek, ami ami nem fogalmi. Abszolút
abszolú. És a a spirituális élmények,
vagy a a zene, van egy csomó olyan
dolog, amit lebutítunk, hogyha elkezdük
szavakkal
méltani, vagy szavakkal reflektálunk
rájuk, és és a művészete kics ilyen
kicsit ilyen. Hogyha bemegyünk egy
kiállítótérbe,
szerintem az is jó, hogyha megpróbáljuk
gondolatindítóként konceptuálisan
megfogni azt a valamit, amit látunk.
De mi van akkor, hogyha teljesen
érzelmileg akar, vagy egy olyan olyan
síkon akar ránk hatni a művészet,
amelyhez már fogalom nem feltétlenül
társítható. És talán ez lesz az AI-nak
is az egyik veszte, h vagy vagy talán
vissza fog jönni az emberiségben ez a az
igény arra, hogy hogy megéljük a
fogalman túli dolgokat, mert mert hogy
az AI az talán abba nem fog tudni
labdába rúgni, mert nem tud nem
fogalmakkal, vagy nem tudom, hogy tud
meg fog-e tanulni, de ez egy érdekes
dolog, hogy hogy mi az, hogy spirituális
élmény és az, hogy lehet szavakkal,
lehet-e szavakk és tud-e bármit kezdeni
ezzel. a mesterséges intelligencia.
Úgyhogy érdekes, érdekes kérdések. Itt
van két gondolatom, tényleg nagyon
izgalmas kérdés, és bizonyos szempontból
örvendek, hogy már elértünk a
művészetekhez, mert mert itt itt itt azt
hiszem, hogy nagyon
érdekes beszélgetésünk lesz. Az egyik,
amit amire akartam reflektálni, hogy én
azért értek tökéletesen egyet veled,
mert azt látom, hogy az emberi
tudás nagyon kicsi része verbális. Tehát
amit egy ember tud, azt jó részt
utánzással tudja, tehát látott más
embereket és megtanulja utánozni. Vannak
rituáliaink, amiket megtanulunk, és nem
tudjuk, hogy miért tesszük azt, amit
teszünk, de de ismételjük. És a
következő szintje a tudásnak az
az arra már a művészek tanítanak meg
minket. Nem tudjuk, hogy miért tetszik
az a festmény, de valamiért tetszik.
Nincsenek szavaink rá feltétlenül, de
valamit megindít bennünk, megmozdít. és
a képzőművészek, a a a költők, a festők,
a szobrászok tanítanak meg minket olyan
dolgoknak a kifejezésére, amikre még
nincsenek szavak. És utána jön majd csak
a filozófia és a verbális tudás, amin
egy nagyon kicsi része, és amúgy nagyon
hasznosnak tartom, hogyha valamit meg
tudunk fogalmazni, de nagyon, nagyon,
nagyon nehéz valamit megfogalmazni, ami
igazán komplex, és bizonyos szempontból
vannak dolgok, amiket nem értünk, és
nagyon jó, hogy felhoztad az AI-t. egy
éve gondolkozok azon, hogy mi is az AI,
mert mert nem nem tudjuk, hogy hogy
tehát az egyik kérdés, amivel
foglalkozok, hogy Decard
úgy úgy definiálta az embert, hogy azt
tesz minket emberré, hogy képesek
vagyunk
gondolkozni és azok a gondolati
folyamatok, amiket mi azzal
asszociáltunk, hogy mi most emberek, ez
tesz minket emberré, úgy látjuk, hogy
lehet ezt automatizálni, hogy képesek
vagyunk olyan gépeket létrehozni, amik
ugyanúgy verbálisan érvelnek, mint és
már megkülönböztetlen a a a az a szöveg,
amit egy AI ír egy ember által írt
szövegtől. Úgyhogy azt jelenti, hogy
hogy vagy nem definiáltuk jól, hogy mi
tesz minket emberré, vagy egyenértékű
emberrel egyenértékű gépeket hoztunk
létre. És én azt hiszem, hogy az első az
igaz, hogy ennél mélyebbre kell menjünk,
hogy mi tesz minket emberré. számomra ez
az a a kiállítás pont erről szól, tehát
hogy mintogyha a művészek birkóznának a
szavakon túl azzal a kérdéssel, hogy mi
tesz minket emberré. Ö ez a a ez is a
tematikája, hogy egy új középkor
a és ez nagyon tetszik, van a fejemben
egy ilyen kép, kíváncsi vagyok a a
véleményedre, hogy olyan, mint a a gitár
húrját, mint am megpengetjük, hogy hogy
vannak olyan pontok a gitárhúrján,
amelyik fixek maradnak, és vannak olyan
pontok, amik kiinganak, és egy ilyen
színuszos görbét ír le, de valójában
ezek a periódusok jól megfigyelhetőek
akár szabad szemmel is. És olyan,
mintogyha a történelem húrján is látnék
ilyen nyugvópontokat, és látnék olyan
pontokat, amikor minden izg mozog és
minden irányba próbálkoznak a a tehát
nincs nyugvópont. És most úgy érzem,
mintogyha a mostani korszakunkban nincs,
nem lenne egy nyugvópont, mintogyha
minden recsegne, ropogna és kérdőjel
mindennek kérdőjelezzük, megkérdez
megkérdőjelezzük a nemek kérdését, hogy
hogy létezik-e férfi és nő, vagy pedig
egy spektrumon mozognak. Megkérdjelezzük
a házasságot, megkérdjelezzük a a az
embernek a a szükségességét, vagy a
hasznosságát azáltal, hogy jönnek ezek a
a a az automatizált gépek. És minthogyha
keresnénk a nyugvópontot. Én ezt éreztem
így a kiállításba, hogy a nyugvó pontot
keressük azt az új reneszánsz embert,
aki aki megint azzal a magabiztossággal
fog jön, mint Káoni János, hogy hogy
azzal a azzal a
a azzal az erővel és magabiztossággal
fog tudni fellépni, hogy az világ megint
értelmezhető, és van értelme alkotni, és
van értelme tanulni,
mert mert nem relatív minden, hanem
vannak olyan alapelvek. Ez is amúgy a
navigátor podcastnek az alaptémája.
Vannak alapelvek. És most felmerül a
kérdése az AI-jal kapcsolatban, tehát
hogy pont az utolsó teremben ezzel
küzködik a a legtöbb kiállítás, hogy ha
ennyi végtelen információ van, ami
körbevesz, tehát hogyha egy utolsó kicsi
címkét is leszkennelünk a vonalkódon
keresztül, hogy valójában egy újabb
kicsi világ tárul fel, hány gigab-nyi
adat van mögötte, ami azt a terméket
leírja, hogy honnan jött és hogyan
tevődött össze. Hogyan lehet ebben a
hihetetlen sok információban, ami
körbevesz és a közösségi médián
keresztül, ami elér minket, hogyan lehet
eligazodni, hogyan lehet tájékozódni, és
hogy van egy, hogyha ha ennyi információ
körbevesz minket, és ráadásul nem
elégíti ki a szomjunkat, ez az
egész ez a, hogy újabb videót nézünk
meg, újabb animációt nézünk meg, és
egyre csak szomlyasabbak, és
szomlyasabbak leszünk tőle, mert ez egy
olyan víz, amelyik nem oltja a szomiat,
akkor lesz-e olyan olyan víz, amelyik
oltja a szomjat. Tehát én ezt látom,
hogy ezzel a kérdéssel küzd jó párt
kiállított tárgy. Nem tudom, hogy hogy
neked mi a véleményed ezekről a
gondolatokról. Így van. Nagyon nagyon
sok olyan tárgy van, amelyik ezt a ezt a
dualitást, vagy ezt a tranzíciós
időszakot hangsúlyozza, vagy vagy mutat
rá. Úgyhogy nagyon jó az olvasatod, vagy
nagyon jó szavakba formáltad azt, amit
éreztél. Látod, ez a ez a nagyon kicsi
szűk százalék, ami megfogalmazható, de
van mögötte egy csomó minden, amit alig
tudok megfogalmazni, és én is ezzel
küzdök. Tehát mi az AI pontosan? Ezzel
küzdök, hogy szavakat találjak arra,
hogy miért ne féljünk a az AI-tól. És
azt hiszem, hogy ez a művészek feladata,
hogy hogy konkrétan
funkcionálisan ti tapogatjátok ki a
szavakon túli doméniumot.
Hát amikor tanítok, akkor akkor azt
szoktam első két első körben bevetni,
hogy mi a művészet
funkciója. Most nem tudom, hogy erre
sokféle válasz lehet. Én alapvetően két
két felé osztom, vagy az egyik
értelmezési
alternatíva az ez két felé osztható.
Az egyik az az, hogy a művészet az
szórakoztathat,
illetve a művészet az az érzelmi
intelligenciánkat
fejlesztheti. Tehát, hogy érzelmileg
intelligensebb emberek legyünk.
Most attól függően, hogy milyen emberről
van
szó, vagy hogy milyen milyen az ő világa
és milyen háttérre rendelkezik,
elképzelhető, hogy nincs igénye az
érzelmi fejlődésre, vagy nincs igénye
arra, hogy megéljen
egy egy katarzistes színházi
előadás után, vagy egy film után. Ő
szórakoztatva akarja inkább érezni
magát. És nem tudom, hogy ez-e
a az általános tendencia, de a
szórakoztatás az talán divatosabb. És
azz az, hogy mi emberekként hogy
érzünk, az sokkal nehezebb. A közösségbe
tartozásnál is a közösség
tagjai csináltak furcsaságokat. Mindig
előbb-utóbb, minél nagyobb a közösség,
és minél több szálon van súlódás, annál
előbb előjöhetnek konfliktusok. De
vagyunk-e elég intelligensek érzelmileg
arra, hogy a másiknak ne csak azt
látjuk, ne csak azt lássuk, amit mond,
hanem hanem azt a a jéghegy, a teljes
jéghegyet lássuk, vagy próbáljuk meg
odaképzelni, hogy amikor valaki, mit
tudom én, dühruhammal közelít felénk,
akkor akkor képesek vagyunk-e arra, hogy
annyira érző emberek legyünk, hogy
tudjuk, hogy az a dükroham az nem
biztos,
hogy mi ok mi válthattuk ki, de nem mi
okozzuk azt a dűroalmot, vagy valami
sokkal mélyebbe, valami tőlünk
kívülállóba kapaszkodhat adott esetben.
És ez ez az érzékenység, ez szerintem
csak úgy fejleszthető, hogyha hogyha
nézünk olyan tartalmakat, amelyeket
nagyon nehéz megemészteni.
És most például nemrég, mert néztük újra
a kedves feleségemmel a az Ádám almái
című filmet, és megint megint
teljesen padlóra vert, és megint megint
szétszedett daramjainal, és újra
összetett. Szerintem ezek ezek annyira
fontosak, hogy hogy érezzünk ilyeneket.
Volt egy Mondjad csak. Igen, ez ez nem
nem ismerem ezt a filmet. Ez miről szól?
egy egy dán film, amelyik egy azt hiszem
dán film egy papról szól,
aki akihez visznek
embereket, ilyen bűnözőket, hogy ott
szolgáljanak egy ideig ennek a papnak
a
társaságában, ennél a
templomnál. És a a
pap, hogy mondjam?
kim kimeríthetetlen, végtelen, tehát
megfoghatatlan
tömegű
hitét teszi párhuzamba egy egy
szkeptikussal, egy hitetlennel, egy egy
náci figurának az energiáival is.
Rendkívül izgalmas,
nagyon meg tudja hordozni az ember. Ez
ez csak egy példa. Rengeteg ilyen film
van
és legtöbbéről nem tudunk.
Én játszottam a diákjaimmal egy egy
játékot, kitaláltam egy játékot,
amelyikben sztori, hogy jöjjak, plot
szinopszisokat találnak
ki. És az egyik csoportom, csapatban
megírta a
szinopszisát egy nagyon hír híres
filmnek. Azóta sem mondom el. Nem tudom,
hogy fogják-e látni, de nem akarom
lelőni a point, mert nem tudják, hogy
melyik filmnek írták meg a a plottját.
És annyira sajnálom, hogy hogy egy
akkora értéket egy
olyan innovatív dologgal nem
találkoztak, mint az a film, amelyik
nagyon is emberi dolgokról beszél és és
olyan kérdéseket tesz fel, amelyiket
amelyiken, hogyha nem gondolkozunk
rajta, megnézzük a filmet és lefekszünk,
de biztos, hogy valahol bennünk dolgozni
fog. Igen, még a én meg akartam
említeni, mondtad a két funkcióját a
művészeteknek. Én volt egy nagyon
érdekes felismerésem, egy ilyen
paradigmaváltás volt. Olvastam az
egyik amúgy ortodox ikonfaragónak a
könyvét,
pontosabban a testvérének a könyvét, és
ott írta le, hogy a szépség az megvéd
minket.
És gondolkoztam, hogy hogyan védhet meg
minket a szépség, hogyan védhet meg
minket maga a a dekoráció, a
a az esztétika. És egyrészt nyilván az
van, hogy ha felöltözünk egy szép
ruhába, akkor is a akkor előcsalogatja
belőlünk a Jobbik énünket. Tehát, hogy
hogy körülbelül úgy képzelem el a
szépséget, mint a leggyönyörűbb nő,
akivel táncolni akarunk, egy gyönyörűen
kidzített terembe, egy tökéletes
hangulatba, és te méltóvá kell válj
ahhoz, hogy azzal a nővel táncolj.
Bizonyos szempontból, ha előcsalogatja a
jobbikénünket,
már kompetensebbekké válunk,
tisztábbakká, erősteljesebbekké. Tehát,
hogyha egy szép szép terem, egy
szép csokorvirág, egy szép
animáció méltóvá kell váljunk, hogy
tehát hogy előcsalogatja a következő
szinten, felébreszt egy pillanatra, hogy
ilyenek is lehetnénk. Ez az egyik, de a
másik ennél praktikusabb dolog volt,
amikor rájöttem arra, hogy a a feleségem
egyfolytában dekorálja a lakásunkat.
Engem közbe bosszant is az igazság, mert
hozza az ikebanát, és már az első
gondolatom az volt, hogy mennyibe került
az az ikebana, és hogy még kellett még
egy ikebanát megvenni a a hetedik mellé.
És az eredménye az, hogy a lakásunk
tényleg szép, tényleg amit lehetett 60
nmből kihozni, azt kihozta a feleségem.
És tényleg gyönyörű
esztétikus, viszont
telített. Amikor ránézek, akkor azt
látom, hogy összességében gyönyörű, de
hogyha hazahozok egy szatyrot és lerakom
a földre, már az az érzésem, hogy hogy
rendetlenné vált a lakásunk, mert
pluszban van benne az a dolog. És így
véd meg praktikusan a szépség, hogyha
nem lenne csak úgy berendezve, ahogy én
legényként berendeztem volna magamtól,
akkor nyugodtan felelhetne mindenféle
szeméttel, meg rendet rendetlenné
válhatna, mert nem lenne mi nem lenne az
az érzésem, hogyha lerakom azt a
szatyrot a földre, hogy hogy az pluszban
van, de a szépség gyakorlatilag betölti
a maradék űrt, a ami ami funkcionálisan
amúgy egy egy üres falak lennének, de a
szépség a dekoratívan be betölti és
megvédi ilyen szempontból Az igazi,
tehát mondjam úgy, hogy a szépség az egy
az egy kontrollált káosz. A de a
kontrollálatlan káosztól véd meg
minket. A szépség az ugye régóta ez
folyamatosan diskurzustár a
művészetben. A
elképzelhető,
hogy szépség is sokféle lehet, vagy nem
biztos, hogy a szépség fogalmába kell
kapaszkodnunk.
Mert az,
amikor az van, hogy valahol otthon kell
legyünk, és van akinek az
otthon azt jelenti, hogy valaki bántja
őket. És ez nagyon szomorús, nagyon sok
ilyen történet van, hogy olyan ember
mellett köt ki, aki aki bántja őt,
merthogy abban érzi otthon magát
valahogy olyan háttérrel
jön, és belülről egy csomó olyan
dologban érez szépséget, vagy
megnyugvást, vagy hogy
mondjam, fészket egy ilyen meleg
valamit, ami amúgy amúgy nem szép
másnak. Tehát úgy, ahogy
valakinek szép tud lenni, és otthon tud
jelenni egy olyan lakás, amelyik úgy néz
ki, mintha ép kiadó lenne. Van akinek
meg meg kell egy kis életszag belé kell
akkor akkor tudja elengedni magát,
hogyha hogyha érzi, hogy most most
elengedhetem a az izmaimat, letehetem a
zacskót. Tehát ez nagyon nagyon érdekes
dolog ez a szépség fogalma, hogyha onnan
közelítsük meg, hogy hogy miben érezzük
otthon magunkat és akkor mindig vissza
kell nyúlni ahhoz, hogy mi honnan
jövünk. És viszont pont te mondtad, hogy
volt egy telítettségi érzeted ezzel a
koni animációval. Tehát az volt az
érzésed, hogy ez elég kerek lett. Ha még
hozzátennél valamit, sem lenne
feltétlenül nagyobb hozzáadott értéke.
Tehát, hogy lehetett volna ennél
egyszerűbb is, és akkor még nem lett
volna telítve, és le tudsz kerekíteni
valamit a maga stílusán belül, a maga
szabályain belül, úgyhogy hogy azt
érezd, hogy ez elkészült.
Szóval ezt ezt ezt arra hoznám, hogy
mint példa, hogy mégsem random minden.
Nem az van, hogy bármi szép, mert hogyha
azt mondom, hogy bármi szép, akkor azt
is mondom, mintogyha semmi sem lenne
szép. Tehát vannak dolgok, amiket széppé
lehet tenni, és van tehát, hogy látod,
és látod a potenciált benne, hogy hogyan
lehetne még szebbé tenni, és még szebbé
tenni, és először és és hogyha eléged
figyelsz rá, akkor el tudsz jutni egy
olyan pontra, amikor azt mondod, hogy
most már tovább nem tudom ezt csinálni,
vagy vagy pedig nagyon-nagyon sok
energiát kéne nagyon-nagyon kicsi
hozzáadott értékkel.
Szerintem, hogyha valaki tud figyelni
arra, hogy széppé tegye a környezetét,
és ebben a így élje meg a mindennapjait,
hogy a környezete, az öltözködése és a
szép által tud több lenni és jobb lenni,
és a legjobb önmagát hozni, az
az az lehetne kábé mindenkinek a
célja, mert az már egy olyan
letisztultságot, az azt jelenti, hogy
már az idődet úgy tudod hatékonyan
öztani, hogy hogy van kapacitásod arra.
Ezt most csak magamra reflektálok, mert
merthogy én ilyen túl túlpörgős fajta
vagyok talán, és
nem mindig nem mindig jut nekem idő
arra, hogy akkor arra figyeljek, hogy
most valami szép legyen, ami ami így a
saját környezetemet
illeti. De hát ez a legbénább
nem érv, hanem mentegetőzés, de hát
művész vagyok. De ez ez ez a kicsi
rendetlenség, ez ez egy érdekes téma,
hogy akkor szeretnék oda kerülni,
szeretnék szeretném úgy alakítani az
életemet, hogy tudjak ezekre a
szépségekre figyelni, hogy hogy tudj
tudjalak titeket követni ilyen szinten.
Tehát, hogy gyakorlatilag az életed több
területén, egyre több területén legyen
ez a telített érzésed, hogy már nem
tudsz már hozzátenni, mert annyira szép
az a része, hogy hogy de még mindig van
az az érzés, hogy még egy kicsit jobbá
lehet tenni, még egy kicsit jobbá lehet
tenni, de mégis van egy ilyen meg tehát
számomra ez az otthon, ami amit mondasz,
az a megnyugvás, az a fészek, amikor az
az érzésem, hogy a lehetőségemhez képest
a lehető legjobb helyzetben vagyok.
Ennél jobbat nem tudom, hogy el tudnék-e
képzelni, keressem és talán kapok, de
kicsit olyan, mint a zene, amelyik már
amúgy is tökéletes, de még izgalmasabbát
lehet válni, mert egy újabb megdöbbentő
fordulattal még izgalmasabbá tud válni,
és nincs felső határa. Igen, ez érdekes.
Most köszi szépen, hogy ezt így
felhoztad, mert tényleg érzem, hogy hogy
talán nagyon sokféle oldalról meg lehet
közelíteni, hogy
hogyan váljunk jobbá, vagy hogyan
motiváljuk magunkat bizonyos dolgokra,
de lehet, hogy ez nekem egy jó
kapaszkodó, hogy egyszerűen csak azért
csináljak dolgokat, hogy azért legyek
hatékonyabb, vagy
olyan fókuszom legyen, hogy tudjam
megvalósítani azt, hogy akkor több szép
legyen. csak így a személyes életem akár
nem feltétlenül szakmás, mert az az
valamelyes rendben van, de de érdekes,
hogy hogy ők az energiáknak a
lavírozásával, hogyha többet adok
valamihez, például erőt feszítek a
a egy közösségre, vagy vagy a munkára,
vagy egy egy alkotói projektre, akkor
valahonnan el kell vegyekm az
energiákból, és akkor ezeknek a az
egyensúlya megtalálam hogy például az
egyik területnek neki fogok rendbe
rakni, és meglepetésszerűen
szinergikusan hat a többi területemre.
Most például ha elkezdek sportolni
kihat az alvásomra, ami kihat majd az
ébr töltött időmre, ami kihat a
házasságomra. És például elkezdek
foglalkozni a házasságommal. Például
én nagyon sokat töltök a feleségem, sok
időt, nagyon sokat beszélgetünk és és
rendszeresen randizunk, de nyilván
amikor randizunk, akkor valamiről kell
beszélgetni. És most legutoljára pont
pont az animációidról beszélgettünk, meg
együtt néztük meg ezt a kiállítást.
Amúgy április 22-éig lehet megtekinteni?
20, úgy tudom, április 20-a, úgyhogy
ajánlom mindenkinek a figyelmébe. És
gyakorlatilag nem csak az van, hogy a a
házasságomban egy izgalmas téma lett ez
a a a művészetek, hogy mi is a művészet
és mi is például a művészet és a
propaganda közötti kapcsolat, hanem
egyszerre felkészültem erre a podcastre
is. Egy nagyon izgalmas beszélgetésem
vagyok most, és nem vagyis nagyon
izgalmas beszélgetésünk van most, és nem
tudom, hogy ennek mi lesz a
következménye. Lehet, hogy pár
hallgatóba meg Pendit valamit, ír egy
pár kommentet. Lehet, hogy legközelebb
egy újabb személlyel fog tudni leülni,
aki már akinek a vállára ráállunk, vagy
bocsánat, ennek a beszélgetésnek a
vállára ráállunk, és a következőt már
onnan folytatjuk. Úgyhogy ezt látom,
hogy olyan, mintogyha az életünk is
egy-egy műalkotás lehet, hogyha jól
csináljuk a házasságunk, a és ezek
szinergikusan, végtelen kombinációban,
meglepetésszerűen találkozhatnak
egymással.
Hú, ez annyira jó gondolat, hogy mi van
akkor, hogyha ma a mostan a mostani
fókusz irányát átteszem valami másra, és
egy másik
irányból próbálom meg, hogy ezekkel a
szinergiákkal
működjön, merthogy lehet, hogy egy
vállalkozásnak a
vezetése, lehet, hogy nem nem egy
művészembernek való sport.
Az erre való fókusz annyi energiát
kíván, meg olyan szinten lehet, hogy
túlgondolja az ember, hogy az már nem
annyira hatékony és elképzelhető. Ki
kell próbálnom, hogy mi van akkor,
hogyha egy másik oldalról közelítem meg,
és engedem, hogy ezek a szálak
végigfussanak. Tehát a a sportolás
általi, jó alvás általi, jó hatékony
ébrenlét általi satöbbi, satöbbi.
Izgalmas. Igen. És Barovási Albert
László mondta, hogy ő naponta 6 órát
dolgozik amiatt, mert az a kutatási
terület, amiben ő dolgozik, az egy hamar
ki tudja magát égetni. Emiatt ehelyett
viszont elmegy színházba, elmegy elolvas
egy könyvet, és azok a hatások, amik ott
érik, hatással vannak a kutatására is.
És
és ez nagyon foglalkoztat engem is, hogy
valójában nekem mi a feladatom, hogyan
tudom azt az életet élni, amivel a
lehető legnagyobb áldása vagyok a
környezetemnek, mert pontosan mivel
vagyok, és mi hogyan tudom úgy kitölteni
az életem, hogy ne égjek ki benne, de
mégis nagyon aktív legyek, tehát hogy
sok mindent sok mindent csináljak. És
azt látom, hogy itt itt valójában
tényleg egy keresés van, ahol az életem
az összes dimenziójába be kell hozzak
olyan dolgokat, ami ami tehát legyen a
fizikai dimenzióban is valami, legyen az
intellektuális dimenzióban valami,
legyen a a spirituális dimenzióban
valami, és az érzelmi dimenzióban is.
Tehát hogy és a utána persze a társas
dimenzióba is, hogy mindig mindenre
legyen példa, legyen sport az életemben,
legyen legyenek újabb gondolatok,
például az intellektuális doménium. Ez
az, amit most itt csinálunk, hogy
feszegetünk olyan kérdéseket, amelyek
bizonyos szempontból engem is
meghaladnak, és téged is meghaladnak.
Gyakorlatilag egy kreatív táptalaj ez a
beszélgetés, anélkül, hogy megszakítana
bárki. Nem cseng a telefonod, mert
kinhagytuk, az enyém se, mert
repülőüzemmódban van téve. És valójában
hányszor adatik meg a lehetőség az, hogy
pláne ebbe a túl
túl informált világba, hogy két ember le
tudjon ülni és másfél órát fókuszáltan
tudjon beszélgetni valami komplexről.
Úgyhogy ez az intellektuális dimenzió,
de a spirituális dimenzión én például
introvertált ember vagyok. Azt jelenti,
hogy fel kell keljek korán, hogy csendet
tudjak magam körül teremteni. Olyankor
alszik mindenki. Ha elindul a nap, akkor
esélyem sincs, hogy igazi csend legyen
körülöttem. Ez például az a pont, ahol
ahol a spirituális részemet tudom
megélni. És persze van az érzelmi rész,
amit mondtam a feleségemmel, a
gyermekeimmel időt tölteni a
munkatársaimmal.
És é és azt látom, hogy az az ember, aki
vagy aki voltam is, hogy bizonyos
dimenziókba belefektettem, és nagyon
megpróbáltam megtolni az intellektuális
dimenziót, és akkor azt reméltem, hogy
önmagában az a az oldalam elegendő lesz
ahhoz, hogy egy teljes életet éljek, de
ez nem igaz, hanem ennek a négy
dimenziónak a kreatív együttműködése
kell ahhoz, hogy folyamatosan egy ilyen
felfel vezetű spirál legyen az életem,
egyre izgalmasabb és izgalmasabb legyen
a a a az út. Ez szép. Kérdeznék még
valamit? Tudom, hogy most már eltelt az
idő, de nem érdekel, mert nagyon
izgalmas, és nem engedlek el addig,
ameddig egy kicsit nem beszélünk a
propagandáról és a művészetekről, hogy
hol látod, hogy hol válik el a
propaganda, mikor lesz egy műalkotás
propaganda és mikor igazi művészet. Az a
az egyik probléma, hogy a
propaganda az negatív értelmű az
általában az embereknek. Pedig a
propaganda az mi? propaganda igazából
egy egy kommunikációs
stratégia,
amelyikben megszűrünk, meg megszűrten
kommunikálunk valamit, tehát szelektíven
kommunikálunk.
És most, hogyha ennek van igen az van,
hogy ez negatív értelmű lett, de van az
a propaganda, amelyik egészségüggyel
kapcsolatos kampány mondjuk, vagy
vagy társadalmi érzékenységre, de ez már
nem művészet fókuszaló fókusz, de lehet
művészet, lehet művészet, persze. Tehát
egy egészségügyi egészségügyi
információt tartalmazó animáció.
Nem fanc például volt egy
egyetemista lány a parciumon, aki aki
művészetbe
fogalmazta az ő betegségét, vagy hogy
mondják, a művészetének a kifejezésének
egy részévé tette az egészség fogalmát,
az ő személyes egészségének a fogalmát.
Tehát és a másik dolog, hogy a művész az
folyamatosan szelektál. Tehát amikor ő
egy témáról beszél, nem
tud objektíven és mindent bemutatni,
tehát nem tudod lefesteni az egész
világot, csak egy t kiemelsz belőle egy
részletet és arra fókuszálsz. Hát nem
nem tudom, hogy hol van igazából, mert
onnantól lehet ez propaganda, vagyis
hogy a negatív propagandát szerintem a
tudatosságtól
lehet a propagandát propagandának, vagy
onnantól hívnám problémás propagandának,
hogyha hogyha ott van mögötte a
tudatosság és az a tudatosság az rossz
értelemben manipulatív. Ühüm. Mert nem
mindig rossz értelemben. És nekünk
művészek én én nem foglalkoztam egész
eddig a a propaganda problémájával, mert
én amikor, hogyha politikai pártnak
készítettünk animációt is, bennem nem az
élt, hogy hogy akkor én most nagyon
tudatosan úgy irányítom, hogy akkor ez
érvényesüljön, hanem tudtam, hogy ennyi
idő van arra, hogy valamit
kommunikáljunk és képtelenség lenne.
Tehát emberi erő, anyagi forrás satöbbi,
mindenféle értelemben
nagy és fölösleges áldozat lenne az,
hogy hogy olyan dolgokra rávilágítsunk,
amik bizonyos értelemben irrelevánsak.
Melyik cég költene arra, hogy a
problémás oldalát reklámozza? Tehát
muszáj szelektívnek lenni, és ez még a
művészetben is ez van, hogy hogy
valamire összpontosítünk, valamit nem
elhallgatunk, de a a lényeget próbáljuk
megfogni. Ühüm. Nehéz nehéz kérdés ez a
ez a ez itt ezzel kapcsolatban van egy
gondolatom. Kíváncsi vagyok a
véleményedre. számomra a negatív
propaganda akkor kezd
el működni, amikor egy alkotó egy elő
előzőleg kigondolt ideológiát próbál
képviselni. Tehát valahol mintogyha
megölnét a kreatív folyamatot, amikor
maga a művész sem tudja, hogy hova fog
eljutni.
amikor amikor nem enged teret annak a
kreatív szabadságnak, ami benne van,
hanem előre tudja, hogy mit fog üzenni
és tud és egy ideológiát képvisel.
Például tegyük fel most megint az LMBTQ
propagandára gondolok, hogy
hogy amikor a Disney rajzfilmben most
nem tudom, hogy figyelted-e, a
Hófehérke most
lett márciusban volt a premiere, és egy
hatalmas katasztrófa lett, és azért mert
az a VOK ideológia lett megfilmesítve,
amit már egy évtizede zengenek, és lehet
fel lehet ismerni annak a mechanizmusát,
annak az ideológiát áját a háttérbe, és
és megfertőztek vele egy olyan
történetet, amit nem szabad nem lett
volna szabad megfertőzni. És ilyenkor
azt látom, hogy ez nem művészet, ez
abszolút ez ez a negatív propaganda,
amikor becsomagol, felhasználnak egy egy
hihetetlenül komplex történetet, egy
örök történetet, ami nem is lehet tudni
hány éves, mert a Grim testvérek
gyűjtötték össze, de ők is
összegyűjtötték valahonnan ezt a ezt a
hihetetlenül szép történetet, és
felhasználták arra ezt a történetet,
hogy a szócsővel legyen valami
olyasminek, ami mint egy ideológia, mint
egy parazita megtámadta a kollektív
figyelmet.
Ez ez ennek az az oka, mert pop, mert
populáris, mert mert hatni kell, mert az
is a negatív reklám is reklám, tehát az
amikor amikor beszélnek rólad, az nekik
van úgy, hogy már sikerül ez nem egy
ilyen példa van rá. És
hát nem tudom a nem is láttam a egész
estés animációkat, nem szoktam nézni,
csak rövid animációkat.
Erről érdemes lemaradni. Erről érdemes
lemaradni. Szerintem sokan, tehát ezzel
lehet, hogy hogy túl sokat nem ártanak,
mert hogyha nagyon negatív a a
visszajelzés, akkor elképzelhető, hogy
abszolút ez egy ez egy csőd most, tehát
a Disney sem fel kell ébredjen most a
Disney, hogy amit csinált az elmúlt jó
pár animációjával, az az propaganda
volult. Hát igen, ez a a popszak nehéz a
popszakma az van, hogy hogy hatni hatni
kell.
Relevánsnak kell lenni, beszélni kell
rólunk, nem tudom mit. Tehát gondolom,
hogy hogy ez az a ezzel a popsággal jár.
Ezért szeretem nagyon a a rövid
animációkat, amelyeknél nem az van, hogy
mögötte Disney van, vagy valami bazi
nagy stúdió, hanem független alkotók
hoznak létre művészi kifejezéseket, és
nem ismerjük azokat az animációkat, a
rövid animációkat, amelyeket mondjuk
Oszkára jelöltek, és Felszből készült
bában animáció és leviszi a fejed olyan
mély és töltetében, érzelmi töltetében
meg hatásában
sok film meg se közelítheti, és ezt csak
10 perc alatt mondta elő. És gyanítom,
hogy az van, hogy a propaganda
végtelenül unalmas is lesz egy idő után.
Hát nem tudom, le az van szörnyű dolog,
de az emberek szeretik. Tehát ugyanaz
van, mint a a híradókban, hogy hogy a
nega, tehát amiről lehet így mondani és
juúj szörnyműködni és nem tudom mi, ezek
ezek lehet, hogy ezek ilyen kulturális
dolog, de azt hiszem, hogy sok embernek
van erre igénye, nem tudna létezni.
Én elmentem
távolkeredre, ültem ott valamennyit, nem
hallottam magyar szót, és amikor haza
visszaérkeztem, leszálltam
Ferihegyen, busz, metró, vonat,
busz, és
addig mind idegen
olyan beszélgetéseket hallottam, amiből
egy mukot nem értettem. Itt pedig ilyen
felhangosodott az, hogy a
tömegközletkedési eszközökön az engem
körülvevő
emberek
90%-a az valakit szapult és
hát csak csupa
negatív vibe-okkal utazgattak a
közvetlen környezetemben. És akkor így
leszálltam a gépről, így így így nagyon
hamar feltűnt már a buszon. És akkor
onnantól így tudatosan csak arra
figyeltem, hogy környezetemre lett volna
fülhallgatóm, tudtam volna magam
szórakoztatni, de így kíváncsi voltam és
egyszer a tévében hallottam egy papot
beszélgetni,
aki aki erre erről beszélt pont, hogy
hogy ez egy ilyen
probléma. Ő úgy úgy gondolja, hogy
hungarikum a panasz. Szerintem nem, mert
britteket is ugyanannyit lehet hallani,
panaszkodni, de ez ez így ez egy ilyen
egy ilyen jelentés egy ilyen jelenség,
ami történik és
nem tudom, mit lehet vele kezdeni.
Hát am szüksége van ezekre az emberek,
szeret, ha valaki ezt meg fogja érteni,
mit lehet ezzel kezdeni, szerintem azok
pont a művészek lesznek. Úgyhogy
kezdjetek el gondolkozni rajta a
szalkotásaitokkal, mit lehet kezdeni a a
negatívummal. Pont az egyik kiállítási
tárgya az az volt, hogy a Facebookot
Facebook logóját azt egy egy ilyen
katedrálisnak ábrázoltam, mint a
katedrálisnak az
alaprajza. Pont ezzel a fajta
marócinizmussal, hogy hogy mivé vált a
közösségi média, lehet egy egy ébredést
hozni, hogy hogy vajában mi is a szerepe
a közösségi médiának, meg mi is a
szerepe? Úgyhogy dolgozzatok rajta, és
nagyon szívesen leülnék veled még tovább
beszélgetni. Az az igazság, hogy még
annyi témán van, tehát most már le kell
zárjuk azt az alkalmat, de például az
AI-ról nem beszélgettünk, hogy el
fogja-e venni a munkátokat, vagy nem. De
nem lesz erre most idő sajnos. Egy
dolgot viszont mégis meg szeretnék
kérdezni zárásként. Mit tanácsolnál egy
fiatal
pályakezdőnek, valamint mit tanácsolnál
egy fiatal érettségizett személynek, aki
érdeklődik a dizájszakma iránt? Hogyan
álljanak hozzá a szakmátokhoz?
maximális
befektetése.
Szerintem az egyik legfontosabb dolog,
hogy folyamatosan magukat próbálják
keresni abba a szakmába. Tehát az, amit
aminek neki fognak legyen, az tervező
grafika, de mindig saját magukra
próbáljanak meg reflektálni, hogy az,
amit csinálnak, az az
őszinte legyen, személyes legyen, minél
több személyes dolog kerül belé.
annál izgalmasabb lesz.
Tehát a sikerre a művésznek az sokszor
abban van, hogy hogy minél többen
értsék. Tehát minél többen tudnak
rezdülni egy alkotással, annál nagyobb a
sikere annak az alkotásnak. Vannak azok
az alkotások, amelyek amelyek kisebb
közönségnek szólnak. viszont tudja az
alkotó magáról, hogy ő csak azt a azt a
kis kasztot próbálja meg megfogni, de
ezt gyakorolni kell, és azt kell
gyakorolni, hogy magunkat fejezzük ki.
És ezért tartom rendkívül fontosnak,
hogy hogy amibe csak lehet, próbálják
meg a saját gondolataikat belevinni.
Nekem nagyon terhes az a helyzet, amikor
kérdezek a diáktól egy valamit, egy egy
problémát meg kell oldani, egy vizuális
problémát, így legyen, vagy úgy legyen.
És ha nem tudom, ez egy nagyon veszélyes
dolog. Ez ez amikor
nincsen nem is kérdezzük meg magunk, nem
is próbálunk valahogy döntést vagy
valamellé valami mellé állni, hanem ott
középen vagyunk megijedve.
Mindegy, egy kicsit ilyen mondjuk lehet,
hogy tínédzserséggel
járó valami, de ezt a egyetemen is
éreztem egy-két társamból. És azt
hiszem, hogy nagyon-nagyon fontos lenne
az, hogy az, hogy nagyon hamar leszokni
arról, hogy mindegy legyen, vagy az
ilyen nem tudomok, amikor két valami
között kell választani, nézzük meg, hogy
melyikben vagyunk mi ott, hogy merjünk
helytelen választodni, vagy nem pontosan
választani? Igen, pontosan merjünk
hibázni. Ez az nagyon fontos ez hibázás.
Én hibázáspti párti vagyok, más nem
lehetek. És
és hogy mindenbe keressük magunkat. Azt
a választ kell adni, amelyikbe egy
kicsit is érezzük magunkat. Ez lehet egy
alkotói dolog, de a problémás mindig az,
amikor amikor félgőzzel csinálja az
ember, és amikor amikor úgy megy be egy
oktatási
intézménybe,
hogy hát jöttem, hogy legyek itt,
legyen diplomám, legyen diplomám,
és abból is lehet valami, de olyan szép
Kiteljesedett életek vannak a am olyan
utak mögött, amelyik arról szól, hogy
hogy őt ő ő magát beleviszi, és onnantól
lesz izgalmas számára is, hogy nem van
nem egy tanárnak próbál megfelelni, és
nem egy nem egy tanárért csinálja, vagy
egy jegyért csinálja, hanem nézi, hogy
hogy ezt úgy próbálom csinálni, hogy én
ott legyek benne, hogy magamnak is
választ adjak valamire. És ez szerintem
nagyon fontos. Igen. Azt hiszem, aki fél
félgőzzel csinálja, azt fogja lecserélni
az AI.
Úgyhogy ennél jobb ennél jobb
gondolathoz zárszóként, amit hoztál,
hogy csináljuk teljes szívvel
és személyes legyen, és releváns legyen,
és ne féljünk a hibázástól, mert egy mi
egyebet tudnánk csinálni, mint
hibázni. Nem is nem is mondhattál volna.
Köszönöm szépen, Zsolti. Ez egy élmény
volt nekem, hogy hogy itt voltál.
Remélem, hogy
hogy szépen fogtok majd haladni ezzel a
közösséggel. Engem nagyon érdekel, hogy
merre halad a kis régiónknak a a művészi
közössége. Sok sikert kívánok neked is,
bátorítok minden egyes
grafikust meg más művészt, hogy merjenek
csatlakozni és merjenek együtt
gondolkozni,
mert mert igen, szükségünk van a
szépségre. Szép napot! Ha tetszett ez a
műsor, akkor iratkozz fel kérlek a
csatornánkra. Ezzel tudsz támogatni
minket. Köszönjük a Week kávé
közösségnek a jó kávéért, az ötvös
udvarnak a helyért, valamint a
bizalomtőkének a támogatásért.
Nélkületek nem jöhetett volna ez létre.